SO JUST A FEW REMINDERS
OF THE MASTER NOT REQUIRED BUT
ENCOURAGED ONE HEARING ROOM IN
ANY OTHER COMMON AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL TESTIMONY
CAN BE PROVIDED IN PERSON AND BY
PHONE. AND THE PHONE CALL IN
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8950 SEVEN
THAT'S. 877-692-8950 SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
. FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN THAT'S.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN IT IS ALSO POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- ON THE VIDEO
FEED. WHAT'S THE PRIMARY SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
TWENTY WILL NOT CURRENTLY WE
ONLY HAVE TWENTY THREE MEASURES
ON THE AGENDA TODAY BUT PLEASE
NOTE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX GRAYSON.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY THREE OH TWO QUIRK HAVE
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING
WE ALSO HAVE THREE CONSENT ITEMS
ON- ON THE AGENDA FILE ITEM
FIVE GRAYSON. FILE ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT KALRA
AND A LOT OF TWENTY THREE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN STONE.
SO THAT THIS- HEARING FINISHES-
IN A REASONABLE HOUR WE ARE
GONNA BE LIMITING TESTIMONY TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER BILL THAT
INCLUDES PHONE AND TESTIMONIES
OR TO KEEP THINGS ROLLING TODAY-
JUST TO RESPECT EVERYBODY'S
TIME. SO JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND
FIFTEEN MINUTES- INCLUDING PHONE
IN TESTIMONY. AND LOOKING FOR AN
AUTHOR I DO NOT SEE WE ARE GONNA
GO ON FILE AND- ORDERS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE BUT- SO- CUTTING.
IT'S ALL YOURS WHEN YOU'RE READY. ABOUT. EASY GOOD AFTER GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWO
NINE FOUR FOUR HI THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO INCLUDE AN EVALUATION
OF HOW CARBON CAPTURE
UTILIZATION SEQUESTRATION
TECHNOLOGIES ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AN
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
UP FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS WE ALL
KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY
HAVING STAGGERING IMPACTS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DROUGHTS WILDFIRES HEAT WAVES
CATASTROPHIC WEATHER EVENTS OF
INCREASING SEVERITY. THESE
IMPACTS ARE ONLY EXPECTED TO
INTENSIFY POSING A SIGNIFICANT
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA. IF
CALIFORNIA HOPES TO COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE STATE LEADERS
WILL NEED TO DEPLOY THE FULL
RANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THIS INCLUDES CARBON
CAPTURE WHICH LEADING EXPERTS
IDENTIFIED AS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF A SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGY TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL
AROUND THE WORLD. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES WITH AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON EMISSIONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS. GIVEN THAT EXPERTS
HAVE IDENTIFIED CARBON CAPTURE
IS A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE. IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO INCLUDE AN UPDATE
ON HOW CARBON CAPTURE IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
VALUABLE IN INFORMING FUTURE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW CARBON
CAPTURE TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE
DEPLOYED AS A PART OF OUR
STRATEGY TO COMBAT THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. JOINING ME I'M BELIEVE
TO TESTIFY I IS A VIRTUAL WELCH
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CARBON
CAPTURE COALITION. I MAY HAVE.
JUMPED UP HERE SEVENTIES HE
ASKED TO PLAY THAT MISTER WELCH
MAY NOT IN FACT OCCUR THERE WE
GO. FABULOUS FINALLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ON VIRGIL WELSH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION WE ARE THE STATE'S
LEADING BUSINESS LABOR
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT CCS TECHNOLOGIES
PLAY A MEANINGFUL ROLE IN-
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO ACHIEVE
OUR AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS- AS
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- VIRTUALLY EVERY LEADING
EXPERT HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT C. C.
U. S. TECHNOLOGIES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE A PART OF OUR EFFORTS
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
CALIFORNIA HAS DOZENS OF-
FACILITIES ACROSS MANY ECONOMIC
SECTORS THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM
APPLICATION OF A RANGE OF
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE
SOME OF THE BEST- GEOLOGIC
STORAGE ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH- WHAT WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE- IS A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT CCS CAN
BE PART OF OUR EFFORTS THIS BILL
AS NOTED- IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT WILL INCORPORATE INTO
THE ANNUAL REPORT THAT CAR
PROVIDES TO THIS LEGISLATURE-
THE ROLE- AND EVALUATION OF THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT CCS COMPLEX
SO- VERY MUCH PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION TO CHILL
THE EMPLOYEES THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. MOVING TO
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. BEAUTIFUL SCENE
NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
. WOULD YOU SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ON YOUR PHONE IF YOU ARE
ON A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
YOUR NUMBER ONCE AGAIN IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT IS ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE'VE ABOUT THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE
BUT HAD. MY NUMBER FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY IT'LL BE
JUST ONE MOMENT FOR A FEW OTHERS
THANK YOU THE APPEAR. WE WERE
BOTH THE LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER
FOURTEEN. I CAN'T GET THE
BOILERMAKERS INTERNATIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE SPENDING WAS
STATE BUILDIG TRADES SUPPORT
ABOUT. THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY LINE NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BENITO WITH
THE LABOR DISTRICT COUNCIL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEEN. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IT IS ONE BEEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY TEARING UP THE
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. SCENE. NINE SO- JUDGE CLOSE
PLEASE I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'LL JUST CLOSE BY RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME PERFECT THE
CHAIR- THAT THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR BOTH HAVE AYE
RECOMMENDATIONS THERE'S A MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO APPROACH
IT WILL TAKE THE VOTERS IN THE
UNICORNS OF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THAT I SAW DOCTOR
RAMBLE IN THE BACK. DR ARAMBULA
PRESENTING AB. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM THE GREAT I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY. I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S GUIDANCE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
FOCUSED ON THE SANJOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. CALIFORNIA'S TOP
LEADERS ARE COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING OUR STATE SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY IS FOCUSED ON
THE URGENT NEED TO IMPROVE THE
AIR QUALITY IN THE EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT MAKE UP THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. IT IS THE FACT
THAT FRESNO COUNTY HAS THE WORST
AIR FOR PARTICLE POLLUTION IN
THE UNITED STATES. ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION.
AND KERN COUNTY RANKS SECOND. IN
FRESNO COUNTY ALONE THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES THERE
ARE NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND CASES
OF PEDIATRIC ASTHMA AND OVER
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND CASES OF
ADULT ASTHMA. THIS CRISIS IS
PARTICULARLY HARMFUL FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
ARE BAD AIR QUALITY COMPOUNDS
ADVERSE EVENTS ON CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT. IN MISSED DAYS AT
WORK AND IMMEDIATE HEALTH L.
AILMENTS AS WELL AS LONG TERM
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. AND AT ITS
WORST WE KNOW THAT BAD AIR
CONTRIBUTES TO PREMATURE DEATHS
. IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY ESTABLISHED
AMBIENT AIR QUALITY STANDARDS TO
ADDRESS THE GRAVE HEALTH IMPACTS
OF AIR POLLUTION. TWENTY FIVE
YEARS LATER THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT STILL HASN'T MET THOSE
STANDARDS LET ALONE MORE RECENT
ONES. THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN THE FACE OF
DECADES LONG HEALTH CRISIS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
MUST ENGAGE MORE STRONGLY ON
THIS BOTH ON MOBILE HOME AND
STATIONARY SOURCES. ULTIMATELY
IT IS THE STATE'S RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
INCLUDING OUR PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CAN
BREATHE CLEANER AIR AND NOT
SUFFER FROM THE IMPACTS OF
POLLUTION. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
SIX ONLY TO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
INVOLVEMENT BY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IN AN EFFORT
VALLEYS AIR QUALITY. THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE VALLEY
RESIDENTS CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER
. HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
DOCTOR CATHERINE GROUP UP WHITE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AIR COALITION AND
GLORIA ALONSO CRUZ PROJECT
COORDINATOR FOR LITTLE MANILA
RISING. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DR CATHERINE GROUP A
WHITE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AIR QUALITY COALITION
WORKING TO RESTORE CLEAN AIR TO
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ON
UNSEEDED YOUR COULD SEND ME WHAT
PLANS WE ARE THE MOST POLLUTED
AIR BASIN FOR FINE PARTICLES AND
ONE OF THE MOST POLLUTED FOR
OZONE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY AIR
POLLUTION CONTRIBUTES TO
NUMEROUS NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS
ECONOMIC IMPACT AND OUR ROADS
QUALITY OF LIFE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. ROUGHLY ONE IN
FIVE CHILDREN IN THE VALLEY HAVE
ASTHMA MORE PEOPLE IN OUR REGION
DIE EACH YEAR FROM FINE PARTICLE
POLLUTION THAN CAR ACCIDENTS THE
WILD FIRES AND- EXTREME HEAT
WHICH ARE ACCELERATING CLIMATE
IMPACTS COUPLED WITH ISSUES LIKE
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC ARE
WORSENING THIS ALREADY DIRE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THE
STATIONARY AN AREA WIDE SOURCES
UNDER THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY OR
DISTRICTS CONTROL OUR WHERE
ENFORCEMENT AND REDUCTIONS ARE
MOST NEED MEET OUR CLEAN AIR
GOALS GIVEN THE DISTRICT'S LONG
HISTORY OF FAVORING INDUSTRY AT
THE EXPENSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
CONTINUE TO BLOW THROUGH
DEADLINES TO MEET STANDARDS THAT
ARE SO OLD THEY CAN NO LONGER BE
CONSIDERED BE CONSIDERED HEALTH
PROTECTIVE. THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAS NOT MET THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE OZONE STANDARD OR
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
STANDARD FOR FINE PARTICLES. AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY CREATES A
MIDDLE PATH BETWEEN A COMPLETE
TAKEOVER OF THE AIR DISTRICT OR
THE CURRENT HANDS OFF REVIEW. BY
REQUIRING A COLLABORATIVE
PLANNING PROCESS THAT ENSURES
INCLUSION OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS WELL
POSITIONED TO ASSIST WITH
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT MEASURES
AND STRATEGIES. NEED TO NEEDED
TO MEET CLEAN AIR GOALS IN THE
VALLEY GIVEN THEIR STRONG
COMMITMENTS ON ELECTRIFYING
MOBILE SOURCES. THEIR HIGH
COMPLIANCE RATES WITH EXISTING
REGULATIONS AND RECENT SUCCESSES
LIKE THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO
PHASE OUT OPEN AGRICULTURAL
BURNING IN OUR REGION. TO HELP
RESTORE CLEANER AND IMPROVE
HEALTH EQUITY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
. FOR A. B. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY.
OUR OUR SECOND WITNESS VICE
CHAIRS ON THE PHONE GLORIA
ALONSO CRUZ AS A BRILLIANT POINT
THANK YOU WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR THE SECOND WITNESS.
WELL CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
ALONSO GROUP FAMILY COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY MEMBER FROM STOCKTON
AND A FORMER US ADVOCATE OR WHAT
I'M GONNA WRITE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY.
I AM HERE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES. ON THE BILL BECAUSE I DON'T
LIKE SOMEONE WHO HAS WITNESSED
THAT THE TRUMP AFFECT OF AIR
POLLUTION IN MY COMMUNITY I
BELIEVE THIS WILL ADVANCE THE
STANDARDS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITIES ACROSS WITHOUT
LOOKING VALLEY. BIKES PARKED IN
THE ONE THAT I GREW UP IN ARE ON
TRACK TO MITIGATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM. STATIONARY
SOURCES. THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
ITS POSITION IN A MULTI LET YOUR
AREA OR INADEQUATE REGULATION OF
STATIONARY SOURCES HAS BEEN
NEGLECTED FOR YEARS FOR YEARS.
AND AS A RESULT IT CONTINUES TO
COMPROMISE THE HEALTH OF MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. FOR INSTANCE
REGIONAL RESOURCES LIKE THE
BIOMASS PLANT IN BOSTON EMIT AIR
POLLUTANTS. THAT HARM OUR HEALTH
AS PART OF A RESEARCH PROJECT
WILL LET HIM KNOW WHAT RISING IN
TWENTY TWENTY I LEARNED A POINT
RECEIVED TRUCKLOADS OF WOODY
WASTE AND IT BURNS SAID THE
FARMS JUST LIKE MANY. OTHERS
ACROSS WITHOUT LOOKING VALLEY
OPERATES TWENTY HOURS. SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK AND PRODUCES
POLLUTANTS THAT AFFECT LOW
INCOME RESIDENTIAL AREA. SCHOOLS
PARKS AMONG OTHER RESOURCES THAT
WERE SEVERELY AFFECTED DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE AFFECTED DUE TO. CLIMATE
CHANGE AND RISING TEMPERATURES.
YOU THINK THAT CARP MY TOOL
HELPS IDENTIFY THAT THEY AREA IN
SOUTH BOSTON. PRODUCES THE
HIGHEST GREENHOUSE GAS. OUT
RIGHT AND BOB. THIS POLLUTION IS
A IN THE LIVES OF OUR CAN. A
WAITING FOR THE CALL AIR
RESOURCE BOARD PM TWO POINT FIVE
TWO ONE FIVE IT'S CLOSE IS FOR
ABOUT ONE TWO HUNDRED. OF DEATH
IN THE FAMILY CAME ALL THE EACH
YEAR MIGHT HELP AND THE HELP OF
FOUR POINT THREE. FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
BREED THERE IS IMMENSE ACTION.
THAT IMPACTS OF AIR POLLUTION
COST OUR REGION MORE THAN SIX
BILLION EACH YEAR. FOR THIS
REASON I ASK YOU TO VOTE YES ON
AB TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SORRY ABOUT
THAT MISS CRUZ THAT WILL GO TO
THE TESTIMONY IN THE BUILDING.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE FOR
SUPPORT. MELISSA ROMERO
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. KILLER ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR BILL
MCGOVERN COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT. SCENE
NINE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S TOM JORDAN I'M WITH THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT. THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY AS IT WILL NOT
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL BENEFIT.
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE CARBS
EXISTING OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY FOR
THE COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THAT
ARE YOUR CURSE BETWEEN LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS AND CAR. ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
MOBILE SOURCE EMISSIONS WHICH
ARE THE SINGLE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STATE'S AIR
QUALITY CHALLENGES. WE AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY FACES ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE COUNTRY. I DO
TO OUR TOPOGRAPHY CLIMATE
GEOGRAPHY IN THE PRESENCE OF TWO
MAJOR TRANSPORTATION CORRIDORS
THAT TRAVERSE OUR REGION. THE
DISTRICT IN CARP HAVE A LONG
SUCCESSFUL HISTORY OF WORKING
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT PLANS TO BRING THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE AND FEDERAL AIR-QUALITY STANDARDS. TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH HE'S ACT
ACTIVITIES HAVE BROUGHT THE
VALLEY INTO ATTAINMENT OF THE
FEDERAL STANDARDS FOR ONE HOUR
OZONE. PARTICULATE MATTER UNDER
TEN MICRONS IN SIZE. THE SIXTY
FIVE MICROGRAMS TWENTY FOUR HOUR
PORTION OF THE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN PM TWO POINT FIVE STANDARD
. THROUGH THE STANDARDS- THAT
BIT THE VALLEY AND CARPET
JOINTLY DEVELOPED- WE ARE ON
TRACK TO RETAINING THE REMAINING
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS THAT WERE
NON ATTAINMENT FOR. AND
DEVELOPING THESE PLANS THE AIR
TO LOCAL LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND
CAR CURRENTLY WORK OINTLY ON
DEVELOPING. THE TECHNICAL
ELEMENTS OF THESE IMPLANTS THESE
PLANS INCLUDING AIR QUALITY MÀ
MODELING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EMISSIONS INVENTORIES. AND AIR
QUALITY MONITORING THROUGHOUT
THE THROUGHOUT THE BUT THE
VALLEY. THESE PLANS GO THROUGH A
LOCAL PROCESS PUBLIC PROCESS
THAT INCLUDES ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THEIR TOP AT A LOCAL PUBLIC
HEARING THEY THEN GO TO THE
STATE THE STATE GO THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS IN A PUBLIC
HEARING. SUBMITS THOSE PLANS EPA
THEY GO THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS
AND PUBLIC HEARING THERE AS WELL
. WE THINK THE CURRENT PROCESS
IS IT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE
INVOLVES ALL THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THE ISSUE- AND- WE THINK
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY WILL ACTUALLY
KIND OF IN P. THAT PROCESS BY
MANDATING A SPECIFIC PROCESS
THAT WE MUST GO TO. IN
CONTROLLING AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
ARE GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO
DEVELOP RULES AND REGULATIONS
OVER STATIONARY SOURCES. CARBS
PRIMARY AUTHORITIES THE
REGULATION OF MOBILE SOURCES.
AND THE AIR DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
REDUCED OVER DECADES HAVE
DEVELOPED RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT WERE BE REDUCE STATIONARY
SOURCE EMISSIONS BY 90% AT THIS
STAGE STATIONARY SOURCES MAKE UP
ABOUT 15% OF THE NITROGEN OXIDE
EMISSIONS AND MOBILE SOURCES ARE
ABOUT 85% OF OUR OF OUR ISSUE.
WE THINK THAT THE BEST WAY TO
BRING CLEANER AIR- TO THE VALLEY
AND THE REST OF THE REGION FOR
THE STATE IS TO FOCUS ON
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO REDUCE
MOBILE SOURCES. THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT WILL NOT STOP ITS
ACTIVITIES TO LOOK AT STATIONARY
SOURCES AND LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT THE BIGGEST
OPPORTUNITY IS THE CONTROLLED
MOBILE SOURCES. AND WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO. CRACKED UP
. MISTER CHAIRMAN YEAH BROWN
INTO IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION- WE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND- REALLY IF WE
COULD BE FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS ON
WAYS TO ACTUALLY GET EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND WE THINK THAT THE
THAT THIS BILL REALLY DOESN'T
PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
FOCUSING MORE BY WILL LOOK FOR
YOU KNOW REGULATORY
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUT ENCOURAGE.
MORE RESOURCES FOR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS SO WE CAN ACCELERATE
REDUCTIONS AND IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH FASTER THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. CENA MOVED TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IN WILL
CUT THE LINE NUMBER TWELVE
PLEASE CONTACT. DANIEL BROWN ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
AT IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK IN
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE
A CLIMB NUMBER FORTY Q. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS MARK
FENSTER BAKER ON BEHALF OF-
CHAPTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THE
PROCESSING OF THE LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR JUST THE BANK
ACCOUNTABILITY CALLING THE
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
AND TO INSIST THAT THE BILL
REASONABLY BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE
THE FALCONS DISTRICT IN OTHER
AIR BASE AND THE LISTING
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION. RELEASE
ONLY A SUPPORT POSITION. THANK
YOU FOR THE RECORD MY NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE. I NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE YEAR OPEN. YEAH THIS IS
BETTER THAN THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL AIR QUALITY
CUSHION CONTRIBUTION SUPPORT FOR
THE CLIMATE CENTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE ABOUT TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. HELLO THIS IS
MARK ROWE'S WITH NATIONAL PARKS
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION CALLING
IN SUPPORT. HEY WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MARKET UP IN THE SEARCH CARE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AS A MESSAGE THANK
YOU- SO- MISTER AMALEK AND COULD
YOU. YOU KNOW MY UNDERSTANDING
HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT. LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS FOCUSED ON THE-
STATIONARY SOURCES AND THE ARB
IS MORE FOCUSED ON THE MOBILE
SOURCES. SO HOW IS THE AIR BE
BRINGING THAT UP AND BRING IN
THEIR B. TO INTERVENE MORE GOING
TO HELP- WITH. YOUR YOUR- YOUR
ISSUES. I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
AFTER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF FOR
STILL STRUGGLING TO GET INTO
ATTAINMENT WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND- ORGANIZATION
WHO'S OVERSEEING IT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE URGENCY. FOR THOSE
OF US WHO LIVE IN THE VALLEY AND
AS YOU HEARD FROM THOSE WHO ARE
CALLING AND SUPPORT TODAY OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE FELT
THE IMPACT OF THIS. BAD AIR
POLLUTION FOR FAR TOO LONG AND
BELIEVE THAT ULTIMATELY THE
STATE BEARS RESPONSIBILITY AND
WHAT WAS LEFT OUT OF THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTARY IS. A
LOCAL LAWSUIT WHICH IS BEING
PLACED AGAINST THE EPA FOR NOT
MEETING AND ALLOWING US TO REACH
OUR STANDARDS. ULTIMATELY
THERE'S SOME- RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE MAY HAVE TO FACE VIA
SANCTIONS AS A STATE IF WE DO
NOT MEET THAT RESPONSIBILITY AND
BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE FROM OUR- AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SO THAT WE CAN-
AFFECT THE CHANGE WE KNOW NEEDS
TO HAPPEN. BY THE WAY THEY
COMMITTEE AND ELSE THIS
INDICATES A- AN AMENDMENT DID
YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT THANK. GOODNESS THANK YOU
MISTER ADDED LIKE THE AIRPORT TO
RESPOND AS WELL. SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY LEE MENTIONED A
RECENT LAWSUIT ON OUR OUR PM TWO
POINT FIVE PLAN THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO EPA AND THERE WERE
A NUMBER OF ELEMENTS TO THAT
LAWSUIT- EPA FOUND IN FAVOR OF.
CARP AND THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
PORTIONS OF THE PLAN AND ALL
AREAS BUT ONE. THEY FOUND THAT
ON THE STATIONARY SOURCE SIDE WE
MET THE REQUIREMENT OF HAVING
MOST TRENCHANT MEASURES WHICH
MEANS BASICALLY OUR RULES ARE
MORE STRINGENT THAN ANY ROLE.
ANYWHERE ELSE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. THE ONE AREA THAT THEY
FOUND OUR PLAN FELL SHORT. WAS A
SHORTFALL IN INCENTIVE FUNDS
THAT WERE COMMITTED TO IN THE
PLAN TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
MOBILE SOURCES- THAT WAS THE
ONLY PROVISION OF THE LAWSUIT
THAT WE WEREN'T MARC SUCCESSFUL
IN DEFENDING. AND AND WE ARE IN
NO WAY SAYING OUR WORK HERE IS
DONE WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT AT
AT THOSE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET MORE MATURE
REDUCTIONS- BUT WE DO FEEL THAT
WERE THE MOST QUALIFIED TO DO
THAT. IN OUR REGION. ADAM OR MR
VICE CHAIR IF I CAN PULL AND DR
CATHERINE GROUP OF WHITE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AIR COALITION AS
WELL TO RESPOND ACCOMPLICE. DR
THANK YOU- SO FIRST I WOULD SAY
THAT THE RECENT DECISION ON THE
LAWSUIT SHOWS THAT WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF OVER RELYING ON
INCENTIVE DOLLARS AND WE CAN'T
JUST KEEP THROWING MONEY IN A
BLACK HOLE AND ASSUME THAT IT'S
GOING TO GET US THERE. BY OUR
OWN ANALYSIS EVEN IF WE WERE
ABLE TO OBTAIN THAT ITS
INCENTIVE FUNDING WE PROBABLY
COULDN'T SPEND IT FAST ENOUGH OR
FIND ENOUGH SOURCES TO CLEAN UP.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE STANDARDS
AND TIME. TO OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THIS BILL THAT I THINK ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE IN THE
CONVERSATION IS- IT'S ONE THING
TO HAVE THE STRONGEST RULES IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO ACTUALLY GO OUT
AND ENFORCE THEM. WHICH THEIR
DISTRICT HAS BEEN LACSON- AND
THERE'S DISAGREEMENT WHETHER
THERE'S BEST AVAILABLE CONTROL
TECHNOLOGY OR BEST AVAILABLE
RETROFIT CONTROL TECHNOLOGY AT
SOME OF OUR LARGEST AND OLDEST
STATIONARY SOURCES. AND THE LAST
POINT THAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT'S WHAT UNIQUE ABOUT THIS
BILL. IS IN TRAINING THE
INCLUSION OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT PREVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN MARGINALIZED IN THE PROCESS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YES. THIS RACE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS I
THINK SOMETIMES WHEN WE THINK
THAT- BECAUSE SOMEBODY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO TAKE CARE OF AN
ISSUE IF WE FIND THAT IT'S NOT
BEING TAKEN CARE OF. THEN TO
FIND SOME OTHER CREATIVE WAYS SO
THAT IS TAKEN CARE OF BECAUSE IN
THE END JUST AS WAS NOTED IN TH
ANALYSIS OF TO MANY PEOPLE THAT
ARE SUFFERING FROM THIS THEIR
POLLUTION. AND WHATEVER WE HAVE
BEEN DOING AND I DON'T THINK IT
IS NECESSARILY SAYING SOMETHING
BAD ABOUT THE BOARD IS JUST
SAYING WE'VE GOT TO FIND
SOMETHING ELSE THEY'RE SAYING.
IT AS I UNDERSTAND IT A NEW
PROGRAM CAN BE PUT TOGETHER AND
THAT WILL BE ENFORCED AND IF
IT'S IF IT. ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH
THEN. SOMETHING ELSE IS GOING TO
BE PUT IN BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT WE HAVE TO PROTECT.
PEOPLE'S LAWNS. ESPECIALLY OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR SENIORS- SO
WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
IF WE HAVE QUORUM. WE WILL JUST
A MINUTE WE LOST ONE TO
OFFICIALLY BACKS IN- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. DR EMMET
WOULD LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR EXTREME AIR POLLUTION
IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS PERSISTED
FOR DECADES AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AFTER PASSING FEDERALLY
MANDATED DEADLINES IT IS TIME
FOR THE STATE TO ENGAGE ON ALL
SOURCES OF POLLUTION IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AGAIN
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS BILL HAS A MOTION TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AS
WE GO TO CORAL TAKE A VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- SO-
GARCIA. PRISON IN A COUPLE BILLS
AND WE WILL START WITH AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FULLER GET STARTED WITH TWENTY
ONE FORTY ONE HEY BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE TEAM FOR
YOUR ANALYSIS. BOTH HIGHLIGHTING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE V. SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAM BUT AT THE SAME
TIME- FORCING US TO TAKE A STEP
BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL APPROACH THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO TAKE WHEN IT COMES
TO FUNDING. THIS PROGRAM IN A
SUSTAINABLE MANNER SO I WANTED
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- WE HAVE
PREPARED SOME. AMENDMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO THOSE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AS IT RELATES
TO THE SUSTAINABILITY OF JUJHAR
FUNDS BEING PUT FORWARD BUT OKAY
I WON'T GO INTO A WHOLE LOT OF
THESE SO JUST SAY THAT THIS IS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND PROGRAM.
SILVER COMPOSITE OVERLOOKED
ESTABLISH A CORPORATE CLICK.
RIVAS FLOOR FLOOR HERE
BOERNER HORVATH HERE FOR A
PURPOSE HERE FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS YOUR MATHIS HERE MCCARTY
. COOL WHERE THIRTY HERE ARE
WRONG ROLL CALL- REYES REYES
HERE SEYARTO STONE WOULD WOULD
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
QUORUM ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR THAT THANK YOU. THE PROPER
PROGRAM ESTABLISHES A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR AB SIX ONE SEVEN A PROGRAM
THAT IS A FIRST OF ITS KIND IN
THE NATION THAT FOCUSES ON A
COMMUNITY BASED EFFORT TO FOCUS
ON AIR POLLUTION THAT'S
IMPACTING. YOU KNOW THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT THAT WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT IN THE PRIOR BILL RIGHT-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT HI THIS IS A WILL IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS WE DO HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CALLING IN.
THE FIRST PERSON IS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN SOUTH
CLOSER QUALITY BOARD MEMBER THE
MANY PER AS FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE. AS WELL AS
CHRISTIAN TOWARDS WITH COMING TO
SEE BECAUSE THE VIOLENT
ORGANIZATION WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ORGANIZING
THESE EFFORTS. THOSE WHO WILL
PROVIDE SOME TECHNICAL-
EXPERTISE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT ARISE
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO
THE PHONE LINES FOR THE FIRST
PRIMARY WITNESS PLEASE. CLOSE TO
REVISE A PRESS COULD YOU HEAR ME
WE HAVE YOU YES. THANK YOU IN
THIS CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. AS WAS MENTIONED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LONGER SHIA. I
AM ON THE CELL CULTURE QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AS A BOARD
MEMBER. AND NOW CURRENTLY THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THE PORT DISTRICT
. IT ALSO HAS A SIX SEVENTEEN
I'M READY AND AS WAS MENTIONED
AS WELL I HAD THE PLEASURE AND
HONOR AS YOU DO TODAY TO ANSWER
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
ONE PEACH TO SERVE AS A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL. I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW THE PORCHES BUILDERS TO NOT
ONLY MY COUNTY. AND THE SOUTH
COAST REGION. BUT ALSO TO ALL OF
THIS IS THAT IS COMMITTEE
STATEWIDE ANDERSON AND THAT I
THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN INTEREST
RATES MIGHT HAVE THE SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY. AS WELL
MAYBE SOME OF YOU- AND YOUR
DISTRICTS. EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY TO
THREE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THERE
DISTRICTS WERE CLOSELY WITH THE
CONDUCT EXTENSIVE OUTREACH TO
LOCAL LEADERS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO FORM AND
MAINTAIN THREE THIRTY COMMITTEES
ALSO KNOWN AS CSCS. THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF EACH
DESIGNATED USE YOUR- THE
MONITORING PLANS ALSO KNOWN AS
CAMPS. EMISSION REDUCTION. HAVE
BEEN AND CONTINUE TO BE
DEVELOPED FOR PROFIT LED BY THE
GSES FOR THE COMMITTEES DURING
COMMITTEE. AND THAT IS A
COLLABORATION WITH THEIR
DISTRICTS. THAT ARE REFLECTIVE
OF THE ACTUAL LOCAL AIR QUALITY
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. THE
PLAN CONTAINERIZED STRATEGIES.
INCLUDING COMMITMENTS TO DEVELOP
NEW REGULATIONS. AND SENSE THAT
SUCKS BETTER RATED OPTION A
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES. FOCUSED
FORTUNATE AND COLLABORATION
BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHER
AGENCIES. KANSEN COMPASS A WIDE
RANGE OF AIR MONITORING PROJECT
. BUT ALTHOUGH THE MONETARY.
OKAY NOT A CSC THIRTY COMMITTEES
PARTIES A LOCAL ISSUES SUCH AS
MOBILE AIR MONITORING AND
DEPLOYMENT OF SENSORS AND
PORTALS TO PROVIDE NEAR REAL
TIME AIR QUALITY INFORMATION.
HIGHER FUNDING MUST BE PURSUED
EVERY YEAR. AND THE AMOUNT THEIR
DISTRICTS HAVE RECEIVED IN THE
PAST FOR AB SIX SEVENTEEN OF
IMITATION IS NOTABLY LESS THAN
THEIR DISTRICTS ACTUAL COST. IN
FACT- THE NUMBER OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMITTEES HAS
DOUBLED. STATE FUNDING HAS
REMAINED FLAT OR DOWN DOWN DOWN
DOWN OF THE LAST FEW YEARS. IT
DECREASED SB SIX SEVENTEEN LONG
TERM FOCUS CENTER POLLUTION
REDUCTION AND IMPROVED COMMITTEE
HELP REQUIRED DEDICATED
EQUIPMENT RESOURCES AND STATIC.
SB SIX EFFORTS LEAST SIX. THE
VISION ONGOING STATE PART IN
THIS. UNSERVED UNCERTAINTY
SURROUND FUNNY MIX OF TO PLAN
AND- THE SEARCHES WERE AS THE
CAPITAL INSURANCE THAT NEED.
STAFFING THE QUICK. AND
RESOURCES IN PLACE NOW WHAT
AGAIN THOSE OF THE MONITOR PLAN
. AND ALSO THAT REDUCTION.
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING THERE
DISTRICT STATE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO ADD ADDITIONAL DISADVANTAGED
COMMITTEES TO THE PROGRAM.
INSTEAD OF FUNDING IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND EXPEDITIOUS WAY TO
BRING EMISSION REDUCTION THE
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS OF THE
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY THOSE
BURDENED BY MOBILE SOURCE
POLLUTION SECOND HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL TRUCKS LOCOMOTIVES AND
OTHER EQUIPMENT. HARPAL
EMISSIONS CAN CAUSE OR WORSEN
HEALTH PROBLEMS INCLUDING ASTHMA
ATTACKS HEART DISEASE CERTAIN
TYPES OF CANCERS AND PREMATURE
DEATH. THERE IS AN URGENT NEED
FOR THE STATEWIDE FUNDING AND
FOR IT TO BE ONGOING ANNUALLY.
WE ARE SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY ONE TO PROVIDE THIS VITAL
IMPLEMENTATION AND SENATE FUNNY
FORTY SIX SEVENTEEN. IF THE
PROGRAM IS ALL THE TO BETTER
MATCH ACTUAL COSTS. AND HELP
MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC UP THE
DISADVANTAGED UNITS NOT THE
STATE. AND I BELIEVE THAT- DEREK
. ALRIGHT IS THERE AS WELL ON
BEHALF OF EACH OF THE IT WILL
TAKE BUT BUT SINCE. THERE
TECHNICAL MATTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MOULANA BACK CHRISTIAN
TORRES. EXACTLY HEARD YES SIR
TWO MINUTES. HER ARE WE ARE JUST
PART OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE
EXISTING BEHIND THE QUALITY AND
CERTAINLY PROTECTION FOR I
WANTED. WHY AND THAT'S THE FACT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM PROVIDER.
COMMUNITY ARE. WE COMPLY UNDER
THE NEW TO INCREASE FUNDING. I
THINK WE'RE OUT GOT ADDED TO THE
PARTY HAS TO MAKE. PASSED HAVE
BEEN DATING. AND EVEN COMPETING
. WE NEED TO INCREASE THE HARDER
PART. NUMBER THE NEW YORK ONE
ARGUED IF YOU VERY WE CAN ALL
THAT MUCH OF A REGIONALLY. WHAT
ARE YOU KNOW YOU CAN MANAGE NOT
TO YOUR OWN COMMUNITY AND WHAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET A JOB THE
BUTTONS THE CARD PINE CURRENT
PUBLIC THAT LINE AND IF WE NEED
TO OKAY. THAT BACK OUT I'M
PEOPLE SO A LOT OF. ARE PROVIDE
EDUCATE INFO IF THAT IS.
IT ALSO BE ANOTHER SEVEN
BUILDING UP IN YOUR PARTICULAR
CHARTER UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY.
HIGHLIGHTED THE CARPET AND THE
THREE. EIGHT BEARS UP. A LOT OF
WORK THERE. IN. AS A MEMBER OF
THE IN WE DIDN'T HEAR YOUR GIRL
COUNTY ALL THE COACH AND YET OF
AIRCRAFT DETECTED ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER SO THEY DIFFERENT BACK
PILOT GRANT YOU BUT YOU DON'T
HEAR ASKING ELEVEN THE WORK ON
THE WE ARE GOING AND WE NEED GET
RESERVE FOR THE WILL THE I THINK
STRATEGIES ARE BEING APPLIED WE
ARE OUT AT THE END OF THE
PROBLEM FUNDING WHAT IS NOT BE
TAKING. RECORDS AND ALL THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING BACK TO THE CAN ROOM ANY
AND SO. AND COMMITTEE ROOM JUST
NAY IN AUGUST PLEASE. ALLEN ABS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. IT WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM SEEN NONE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SCENE NINE.
ABOUT A LOTTERY WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY ONE. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO-
OPPOSITION SUPPORT. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING UP TO
VIEW LOOKING FOR CARE PLEASE
CONTACT. ALL RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
. AS A MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE OUT JUST CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW THE LACK OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE'VE HAD
COMMUNITIES I DECLINE THE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS- ONE OF A
KIND PROGRAM D. TO SUMMARIZE THE
GOAL OF THE BILL IS TO HAVE A
CONTINUOUS SOURCE OF FUNDING SO
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES CAN
IMPLEMENT THEIR PLANS AND FUTURE
COMMUNITIES- CAN BEGIN
DEVELOPING- THOSE PLANS- AND BE
IMPLEMENTED EFFECTIVELY WE TAKE
AWAY FROM THE ANALYSIS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO. LOOK AT
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO HAVE A MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE PROGRAM WE AGREE
WITH THAT- ANALYSIS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I THINK ONE THING WE ALL
AGREE ON IS THAT THERE HAS TO BE
A FUNDING MECHANISM THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE IN ORDER FOR THESE
PROGRAMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
MAPS ACTIVE LEGAL JERRY THIS
FLORA NO THE FLOOR NOPE.
BOERNER HORVATH. THREE HUNDRED
FIVE. OR HER BY FRIEDMAN. GARCIA
MATHIS. MATHIS WHERE THIRTY FIVE
MURATSUCHI I. RAY I SAY ARE TO
STONE WHAT. THE BILL HAS TO BE
ABLE TO LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
OTHER MEMBERS AND LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX. I HAVE A
DIFFERENT- TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN YES SIR SORRY BOUT THAT
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
THAT APARTMENT UPON A MEAN TO
INVEST SEVEN POINT FOUR THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER TO
RESPOND TO THE WIDE ARRAY OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS IN OUR
STATE MANY OF YOU MAY BE
WONDERING. WHY IS THERE BOND OF
THIS MAGNITUDE IN FRONT OF US
GIVEN THE STATE'S SURPLUS AND I
WOULD JUST RESPOND BY SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW THE CLIMATE CRISIS
IS FAR MORE EXPENSIVE THAN SEVEN
POINT FOUR. THREE BILLION AND-
THIRTY FOUR BILLION OR WHAT THE
NUMBER MIGHT BE PROJECTED FOR A
SURPLUS. WHAT THIS ALLOWS US TO
DO IS TO. HAVE OUR BODY IN THE
ASSEMBLY SET SOME PRIORITIES
WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS. AND HAS- THAT WAS
VERY HELPFUL LAST YEAR. IT
ALLOWED US TO ENTER INTO BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS TO PRIORITIZE-
CERTAIN ITEMS. THAT WE WANT TO
PUT FORWARD FIRST. THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO MAKING THESE LARGE
INVESTMENTS ON THE CLIMATE
IMPACTS THAT WERE SEEN. AT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE. M.
WISHFUL THINKING WOULD BE THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
POLICY. AND THESE INVESTMENTS
AND PUT IT BEFORE THE VOTERS BUT
WE RECOGNIZE ALSO- THE EIGHT-
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE'RE- FACING. AND THE BUDGET
SURPLUS THAT'S BEFORE US SO
HOPEFUL THAT. THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO INFORM THE BUDGETARY PROCESS
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO OR TIES
WHAT'S IMPORTANT- TO
CALIFORNIANS. FROM ASSEMBLY
PERSPECTIVE FOR PURPOSES OF
INVESTMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HAVE NO LEAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM FOR AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. IT'S
A SEVEN MILE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORTS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT-
WITH THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION WITH REGARD TO. THE
PRIORITIZATION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
. MICHAEL DEFT WITH THE PREY AND
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. C. NONE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM TO AB TWENTY
THREE SEVEN. SEEING NONE MADAM
MODERATOR. BY LOTTERY LEGAL
COMPLIANCE FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR FRIEND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL CALL NINE FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS MARK SPENCER MAKER
ON BEHALF OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY CONSERVATION COMMISSION
AND MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE SIXTY A LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON I CAN
DELFINO ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE SNOW MILAN
TRUCKED IN SUPPORT. AGAIN WE
HAVE NO OVER NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK
YOU BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. THIS MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER CO I HAVE
APPRECIATE THE APPROACH IN
RECOGNITION THAT A LOT OF THESE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO. HAVE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ESPECIALLY ON
OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE NON OUR
ENVIRONMENT- RECENT HISTORY
SHOWS US THE BONDS JUST SIMPLY
DON'T WORK THAT THE MONEY
DOESN'T SHOW UP- AND FOR THAT I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE. SEVEN WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. BUT IT'S HARD NOT
TO TRY TO- TO RESTRAIN FROM
RESPONDING TO THAT BUT I YOU
KNOW HAVE BEEN SEEN QUITE A BIT
OF DOLLARS FROM THE HISTORIC
PARK INVESTMENTS GOING TO
DISTRICTS LIKE MR MAT THIS
DISTRICT OF MISSILE GOMEZ REYES
MISTER MURATSUCHI I'VE SEEN SOME
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR WATER IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAJOR INVESTMENTS
HAVE GONE TO ADDRESSING MANY
PRIORITIES IN OUR DISTRICTS ALL
SEE NEW RIVER AND THE LAW THE
LIST IS VERY LONGNIGHT I WOULD
HOPE THAT- MAYBE WOULD TAKE A
STEP BACK REASSESS YOU KNOW WHAT
INVESTMENTS YOU MAY BE REFERRING
TO WHICH I WOULD IMAGINE STORAGE
AND OTHER TYPES OF PROJECTS OF
THAT SORT THAT YOU'RE MAKING
REFERENCE TO BUT- TO JUST
BLANKET. STATEMENT SAY THESE
DOLLARS ARE NOT MAKING THEIR WAY
TO- THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
ARE INTENDED TO WOULD BE A VERY
RESPONSIBLE WAY OF DESCRIBING
HOW. THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
IMPACTING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW NEXT WEEK
I'LL BE DOING A NICE BIG CHECK
PRESENTATION OF EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO COMMIT IN OUR
AREA THAT WILL HAVE THE FIRSTPARK EVER INVESTED IN INTEL AND
TECH COMMUNITY SO. I JUST WOULD
SAY THAT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE A LOT OF RESOURCES AT
TO INVESTED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO SEE HOW WE CAN GET SOME OF
THOSE DOLLARS. CONTINUING TO
FLOW TO YOUR DISTRICT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS BILL ENJOYS A
MOTION THAT DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS AS A CRITICAL.
RIVAS FLORIDA VOTING. OR NOT
VOTING. BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN SEE A
MATHIS NO MESSAGE NUMBER G.
THREE G. I. REYES. YES I SEYARTO
STONE WOULD. THE BILL HAS TO GO
TO LEAVE IT ON CALL AS WELL AND
MOVING ON AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN AS MUCH FUN AS I'M HAVING
LOOKED TO BE HERE ALL DAY THIS
IS OUR LAST BILL THAT WAS AND
WHAT I SEE HERE THIS BILL
ACCELERATES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
FROM RESOURCE TO PROVIDE
RELIABILITY AND VERSATILITY TO
OUR ELECTRIC GRID- WHILE HELPING
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS ENERGY TIME
AND GOALS I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
JAN SMITH JONES CEO OF THE
INDEPENDENT RG PRODUCERS. SO SEE
ASIAN AS WELL AS- V. JOHN WHITE-
WITH US FROM THE POWER CAMPAIGN
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A TWO
MINUTES PER WITH US PLEASE. YES
JANICE MANY JONES FROM THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
WHICH REPRESENTS A- BROAD
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO OF. LOCAL
RESOURCES IN THE STATE- GETTING
TOWARDS GHG GOALS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE OF A WIDE VARIETY OF
THESE RESOURCES AND SOME THAT
CAN RUN. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
PRODUCING POWER. I CALIFORNIA'S
BLESSED WITH HAVING. A PORTFOLIO
OF- WHITE. A BIRD FLU BY
RESOURCES INCLUDING GEOTHERMAL
BIOMASS AND OTHER- RESOURCES
THAT THAT WE CAN- POTENTIALLY
DEPEND ON. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WILL OF DIRECT. HELP
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND PVC. TO ACTUALLY-
TAKE UP. BOTH PLANNING AND
PROCUREMENT ACTIONS THAT WOULD
LEAD TO- PERHAPS THE USE OF
THESE RESOURCES PETER. THANK
MISTER MEMBERS JOHN WHAT WITH
THE POWER. OF WE SEE US THIS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WE NEED A
BALANCED PORTFOLIO OF CLEAN
RESOURCES AND A COMBINATION. OF
BOTH FARM AND OF RENEWABLE
RESOURCE WE HELP THE GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES AND STORAGE RESOURCES
WE THINK THIS IS A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT BILL AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. IN THE
SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF CLEANER TASK
FORCE INTERESTED FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON PAUL WOODS WITH
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. CM NINE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. CNN
COMMITTEE ROOM AT A MODERATE GO
TO PHONE LINES SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR PREFERRED
SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO
LINE IS SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
CRISTINA CRISTINA CRANKS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STORAGE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OTHER LINE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE WERE IMPORTANT CLOUT.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT FLYING
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW WE CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO
OKAY- I'VE BEEN IN THE QUEUE FOR
OVER FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO SPEAK
ABOUT AB. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE MANAL ALL WRONG BUILDING.
I'M SORRY I UNDERSTAND WHAT AB
TWENTY W. SEVENTH. MADAM
MODERATE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BORDERLINE SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MISTER KAREN THIS IS ALLEY DO
TRIO WITH THE MICROGRID RESTART
THE CALL US AND CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER THE LINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY ARE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FOREIGN
ENERGY IMPORTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
. AGAIN WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NON. CEMENT WHICH
ARTICLES RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS MOST AS A
DO PASS OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS
OBJECTIVE LEGAL RIVAS WITH
MOTIONS AND WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION. FLOOR HIGH FLOOR HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA MATHIS- MATHIS I READ TWO
G. TO G. I. REYES. REYES AYE
SEYARTO STONE WHAT. WELL AS BY
THOSE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
AND- GONE YOUR FINAL BILL YOU
KNOW I THINK I MAY HAVE SPOKEN
TOO SOON EARLIER I HEY- SO I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF WE'RE MORE EXCITED
THAN THE- CRITICAL FUNDING
SOURCES TO THE PART MORE PROGRAM
IS INTENDED THIS BILL WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES- BRENDAN TOY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL AND
BUILD A GOVERNMENT POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR COALITION FOR
CLEANER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST WITH US PLEASE TWO MINUTES
SIR. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BRENDAN TO WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS IN COOPERATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS ADMINISTER THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL AND COST EFFECTIVE
CARL MOYER PROGRAM. SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CENTERED- COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
HAS ENABLED BE. VOLUNTARY
REPLACEMENT SCRAPPAGE OR REPOWER
OF OVER SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
ENGINES. AND THAT'S RESULTED IN
THE REDUCTION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EXCUSE ME
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND.
TONS OF NITROGEN OXIDES IN
REACTIVE ORGANIC GASES WHICH
CONTRIBUTE TO SMOG FORMATION.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO REDUCED OVER
SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED TONS OF
PARTICULATE MATTER. NOT MUCH OF
WHICH IS DIESEL EXHAUST AND AIR
TOXIC AND THAT WE ALSO
ADMINISTER THE OUR DISTRICTS TO
THE LOCAL AB NINE TWENTY THREE
INCENTIVES PROGRAMS. AND- THAT
ALLOWS US TO- CLEAN UP SCHOOL
BUSES- AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT
LIGHT DUTY SCRAPPING PROGRAMS
AND ALSO CARL MOYER QUALIFYING
PROGRAMS. AND THEY'RE- ALL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL TO
ATTAINING HEALTH BASED NATIONAL
IN CALIFORNIA BE AN AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. AND FOR CUTTING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL EXHAUST AND
THAT WOULD JUST SAY THAT CARS
TRUCKS AND TRAINS AND OTHER
MOBILE EQUIPMENT PRODUCE MORE
THAN 70% OF CALIFORNIA'S AIR
POLLUTION. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CUT THESE EMISSIONS UP 280%
BY THE MID TWENTY THIRTIES TO
MEET STANDARDS AND I'LL JUST
FINISH BY SAYING IT EXTENSION
EVERY AUTHORS REAUTHORIZES KEY
FUNDING SOURCES FOR CARL MOYER.
A. B. NINE TWENTY THREE LOCAL
INCENTIVES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THAT WILL ACCELERATE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY DRIVER IN
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO MY
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
. OUR MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION LAST WEEK CAME OUT
WITH ITS AIR POLLUTION GRADES
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND THE
BAD NEWS IS WE'RE NUMBER ONE
CALIFORNIA HAS. REALLY DOMINATED
THE RANKINGS OF THE AREAS WITH
THE WORST AIR POLLUTION IN THE
STATE INCLUDING. LOS ANGELES
BAKERSFIELD FRESNO SACRAMENTO
MANY OTHER AREAS- AND IS DOCTOR
ARAMBULA POINTED OUT EARLIER
TALKING ABOUT HIS BILL. THIS BAD
AIR QUALITY BOTH JEOPARDIZES THE
HEALTH OF OUR RESIDENTS. AND
PUTS US AT RISK OF FEDERAL
SANCTIONS INCLUDING THE LOSS OF
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING. THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE HAVE SOME PROVEN
SOLUTIONS THAT WORK ONE IS
STRONG STANDARDS. BUT ALSO
COMPLEMENTING THOSE STANDARDS
WITH INCENTIVE DOLLARS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
IT WOULD RE AUTHORIZE PROVEN
PROGRAMS. TO CHANGE OUT DIRTY
ENGINES FOR MUCH CLEANER
TECHNOLOGIES AND- BECAUSE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE BROAD
SUPPORT AND WE URGE YOU TO.
CONTINUE TO AUTHORIZE THEM AS
THIS BODY HAS MANY TIMES IN THE
PAST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. THE COMMUTER
COME UP. ISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COTTON
GROWERS JENNER SOCIAIS ASIAN
WESTERN ACT PROCESS TO STATION
NEEDS A FARMER'S LEAGUE IN A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT. TOM
JORDAN WITH THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR AIR DISTRICT A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICOLE KOREAN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT- THIS
PROGRAM ALSO FUNDS CALIFORNIA'S
TIRE RECYCLING PROGRAMS FOR AND
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FULL OF CRAP ON THE HAVE
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE'RE A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MUCH. ALLEN
ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT CO
SPONSOR ALSO IN SUPPORT. PAUL
WOODS WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISORS
ON BEHALF OF THE BIO AND ENERGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE TO SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEE ROOM SEE NOT ANY
OPPOSITION. TO AB. TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX SEEN ON THE COMMITTEE
ROOM MATAMATA REALLY GO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX. YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN IT IS ONE AND
THEN THERE UP IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I WILL GO LINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
ABROAD ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILL
PAIR IT WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT I'M ALSO REPRESENTING
ASTHMA CARE PROVIDERS PHYSICIANS
AND OTHER HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
RECALL TO REGISTER THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE IS SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TREATABLE WITH PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GET THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL THE LINES
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE SIXTY
THREE LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE HAVE
A SIGN ME UP. OKAY NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS JASON ACTED ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOB GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
REX W. HI MY BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAPPIE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NATIONAL
GUARD LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BOW BILLER ON BEHALF OF BRUCE
DOUBLE THE MACCREADY AND UPS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON QATAR
MEDINA WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL TO SUPPORT. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
TO THE COMITTEE. THIS REYES.
THANK YOU. MR GARCIA APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AB EIGHT THESE ARE
IMPORTANT FUNDING MECHANISMS FOR
A VARIETY OF CARE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY PROGRAMS IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME SINCE THE LEGISLATURE
IS EVEN REVIEWED THESE I HAD A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THEM. BUT OUR
STORE FLEET THEY'VE BEEN DONE AS
A PACKAGE OF FEES AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FEES IN
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND JUST THE
PORTION OF THE AB EIGHT FEES BUT
NOT ALL OF THEM SUCH AS THE ONES
THAT SUPPORT THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AT THE C.
C. I BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE. FOR QUALITY GOALS I HOPE
THAT AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WILL CONSIDER. IN YOUR BILL WITH
THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. IF
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTO
ANY OTHER QUESTION COMMITTEE.
SEEN NONE. GARCIA I JUST WANNA
SAY FROM A- CENTRAL VALLEY
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS- THESE PROGRAMS SINCE I'VE
BEEN ELECTED HAVE BEEN SOME OF
THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT WE
PUT THROUGH- AS IT RELATES TO
OUR AREA SO I APPRECIATE THAT A
LOT OF TIMES ABOUT HIS TO GET
LEFT OUT. ASSEMBLY CONVERSATION
SO IT'S MEANINGFUL AND I JUST
KNOW THAT WE APPRECIATE AS A
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS AND-
WHICH I TO CLOSE THANK YOU AND-
WE WILL KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. AND APPRECIATE-
YOU SPENDING THIRTY MINUTES OF
YOUR TIME WITH ME TODAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OUR
PLEASURE. THE COUPLE THE MOTION
IS THE BEST APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS
FLORA FLORA AYE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS
AYE WE'RE TOO CHEAP MURATSUCHI
I. REYES REYES AYE SEYARTO STONE
. WOOD. TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
THIRTY SIX- STONE I WOULD. THE
BILL SEVEN BOTH LEAVE IT OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA JUMP DOWN TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY. AT THE ONE BEST PLAN FOR
THE ACT.
THANK YOU BACK IN HIS CHAIR FOR
THE ACCOMMODATION I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
WHICH SEEKS TO SHUT DOWN THE
COSTA ONCE THROUGH COOLING POWER
PLANTS- ONCE AND FOR ALL IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. THE STATE
ADOPTED MORE THAN TEN YEARS AGO
THE POLICY TO PHASE OUT THE USE
OF THE COASTAL ONCE THROUGH
COOLING. NATURAL GAS POWER
PLANTS. IN TWENTY TEN THE STATE
WATER BOARD ADOPTED A
REGULATIONS TO PHASE OUT THE USE
OF ONCE THROUGH COOLING- PLANTS
HOWEVER WINDOWS TEN YEARS CAME
IN TWENTY TWENTY. THE STATE
WATER BOARD WORKING WITH OUR
POWER AGENCIES THE P. YOU SEE
THAT THEIR- CC AND CAL AYE SO.
DETERMINED THAT FOR THE SAKE OF
GRID RELIABILITY THAT THEY
NEEDED TO EXTEND IT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR. WE AGREED TO
THAT AT THIS SCHOOL YEAR. ON THE
THOMAS THAT THAT WAS IT WAS NOT
GOING TO BE EXTENDED ANY FURTHER
. COM THE END OF- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE STATE WATER BARD- IN
RESPONSE TO THE- PUBLIC SAFETY
OF POWER SHUT OFFS THAT WE
EXPERIENCED IN- THAT SUMMER.
ONCE AGAIN EXTENDED THE
OPERATION OF THE ONCE THROUGH
COOLING POWER PLANTS SO WE ARE
HERE. TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY. TO ENSURE THAT THERE WILL
BE NO FURTHER EXTENSIONS OF THE
ONCE THROUGH COOLING POWER
PLANTS-IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY WE
INCLUDED AN AMENDMENT- IN
CONSULTATION WITH THIS COMMITTEE
. TO EXTEND THE OPERATION OF
THESE ONCE THROUGH COOLING
PLANTS ONLY IF SACRIS THE
ADVISORY AGENCY THAT INCLUDES
THE CDC THE PC HI SO AND THE
STATE WATER BOARD. FINDS THAT NO
FURTHER EXTENSION IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO ENSURE
GRID RELIABILITY. THE PC
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THEY DO NOT
FORESEE ANY NEED FOR ANY FURTHER
EXTENSIONS AND IN FACT THE SACK
WAS MARCH TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
REPORT CONCLUDED THAT CURRENTLY
SACK WAS DOES NOT RECOMMEND ANY.
CHANGES TO THE COMPLIANCE
SCHEDULES INCLUDING THE CURRENT-
EXTENSION OF FOR THE AND THE
CURRENT DEADLINE FOR THE
SHUTTING DOWN OF THE POWER
PLANTS BUT WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
MAYOR BILL BRAND OF THE CITY OF
REDONDO BEACH WHICH IS THE
LOCATION OF A ONE OF THE-
COASTAL ONCE THROUGH COOLING
POWER PLANTS IN OPERATION
AFFECTED BY THESE DECISIONS. AND
THEN WILL HAVE SEAN BOTHWELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE K.
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPERS
ALLIANCE- TO ALSO TEST FOR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GIVEN TWO MINUTES PURPOSE
PLEASE. SUBMIT AFTER NOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
FLEW UP HERE FROM REDONDO BEACH
THEY'RE WORKING ON THIS FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS PRESHOW YOU TAKING
YOUR TIME. MY NAME'S BILL BRAND
OF THE MAYOR DOWN A BEACH FOR
FIVE YEARS WAS COUNCIL MEMBER IN
THE DISTRICT FOR EIGHT YEARS
PRIOR. I WAS FIRST INVOLVED
COMMENTING ON THIS ONCE THROUGH
COOLING LEGISLATION WAY BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. I USED TO BE
A CHEMICAL ENGINEER SOME VERY
COMFORTABLE DISCUSSING THESE
VARIOUS TECHNOLOGIES. WE'VE HAD
A LARGE POWER PLANT OWNER COAST
IN REDONDO BEACH FOR OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YEARS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT THIS
PARTICULAR PLANT IS NOW ALMOST
SEVENTY YEARS OLD. NINETEEN
POWER PLANTS RECITED ON THE
COAST CALIFORNIA TWENTIETH
CENTURY TO USE OCEAN WATER. TO
COOL THEIR OPERATIONS CAUSING
TREMENDOUS DAMAGE TO THE LOCAL
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS. EVERY
LIVING ORGANISM THAT JUST SUCKED
INTO THESE MASSIVE INTAKES
FOURTEEN FEET IN DIAMETER. IN
THE CASE OF REDONDO BEACH DIES.
PARTICULARLY THE PLANKTON AND
OTHER BUILDING BLOCKS OF A
HEALTHY MARINE ENVIRONMENT. THEY
CANNOT BE SCREENED UP. OUR STATE
WATER BOARD PASSED WHAT IS KNOWN
AS ONE THROUGH C
GULATIONS WAY BACK IN TWENTY
TEN TO PHASE OUT THE USE OF
OCEAN WATER TO COOL THE PLANTS
THEY WORK CLOSELY WITH THE STATE
ENERGY AGENCIES AND POWER
COMPANIES TO ESTABLISH DATES.
WHERE THEY WOULD EITHER RETOOL
OR PERMANENT RETIRE WITHOUT THE
LIGHTS GOING OUT THE STATE'S
WORST AMBUSH TWELVE YEARS AGO.
AND THESE DATES WERE EXTENDED
FOR FOUR POWER PLANTS BY THREE
YEARS AFTER A POWER SHORTAGE
BACK IN TWENTY TWENTY. THAT IS
SINCE BEEN ADDRESSED. BUT NO ONE
CURRENTLY SERVING ON THE WATER
BOARD WAS AROUND WHEN THIS
LEGISLATION WAS CRAFTED AND
IMPLEMENTED SO THEY CONTINUE TO
EXTEND THESE DEADLINES AS
COMPANIES LIKE. A. S. REDONDO
TAKEN FORTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR JUST TO BE ON THE READY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THERE ARE
CALLED UPON TO OPERATE OR NOT.
CITY CURRENTLY LOST A FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
RESTORE THE WETLANDS HERE
BECAUSE OF THESE EXTENSIONS. IS
LONG ESTABLISHED RETIREMENT
DATES HAVE TO MEAN SOMETHING.
AND IT'S CLEAR TO ME AFTER
ATTENDING EVERY HEARING THAT
ONLY LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS GOING
TO PREVENT THESE PLANTS. FROM
CONTINUING TO OPERATE.
LEGISLATION IS WELL THOUGHT OUT
IT ALLOWS THESE OLD POWER PLANTS
TO CONTINUE OPERATING. IF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY ACCEPTS IT AND
SACRIS AGREES. SIR DO TO SUPPORT
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY TODAY THE
ENERGY AGENCIES AND PARA
COMPANIES WILL MEET THE
CHALLENGE. BUT ONLY IF YOU PUT A
STOP TO THE IDEA OF SIMPLY
EXTENDING. THE OPERATION OF
SEVENTY YEAR OLD POWER PLANTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MAYOR GOING TO THE
PHONE LINES A MISTER BOTTLE.
THANK YOU CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME SEAN BOTTLE IN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF MY
RELATION WITH THE LEADING
GOVERNMENTAL GROUP TO GO
SHOOTING THE ONE WHO CALLED THE-
PROMISE THAT A DECADE UP UNTIL.
IT WAS ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN. THOUSAND OPTION I
PERSONALLY BEEN THE MAIN IN IN
PROBABLY ONE OF THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT REALLY DIDN'T WATCH ****
BILLION HIGHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ONE BECOMING POLICY OVER THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS. TO ABOUT
BACKGROUND I JUST WANTED TO HELP
ME BECAUSE KEEPER AND ARE
HELPING WATER KEEPERS ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FORTY- I'M I'M GOING
TO JUST BE CLEAR THAT WE DON'T
TAKE POSITIONS ON LEGISLATION
REGARDING THAT. THAT'S ONE TO
COLLECT POLICY VERY LIKELY-
GIVEN OUR LONG HISTORY OF COMING
TO COMPROMISES WITH THE STATE
WATER BOARD ON THE WHAT. WE CALL
THE WE DON'T USUALLY TAKE
POSITIONS WE DON'T PICK IT IS
LAW QUICKLY THAT DIFFER FROM THE
INTENT OF THE WHAT THE COOLEY
ALL. BUT IN THIS CASE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL ALIGNS PERFECTLY
WITH THE INTENT OF THE ONE WHO
CALLED ME UP. AND I'LL JUST
SECOND THE PERSON SPOKE BEFORE
THE KNOWLEDGE ON THOSE WATER
BOARD HAS CHANGED DRASTICALLY-
WHERE WE REALLY DO NEED THIS
LEGISLATION. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
IS CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING THE
GOAL. OF THE WANT TO COMPULSORY
PURCHASE THE PHASE OUT THE
DESTRUCTIVE AN AWFULLY PRACTICE
OF WITHDRAWING MILLIONS OF
GALLONS OF WATER DAILY. KILLING
ALL THE MARINE LIFE ALONG WITH
IT. WANT TO COULD POSSIBLY MAKE
A CLEAR DETERMINATION ALL POWER
PLANTS SHOULD HAVE PHASED OUT
WHEN THE GOING BY. OCTOBER FIRST
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. AND ALL
FUTURE CARPET BUT HAVE A COMMON
COMPLAINT BYTHAN ARE REQUIRED
TO PAY MITIGATION FEE. BUT THAT
APPLICATION FEE OF NOT ACTED AS
A DETERRENT FOR POWERPOINT THE
COMPLY WITH THE POLICY. OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE SEEN DELAY AFTER
UNNECESSARY DELAY AND THIS BILL
THIS BILL WILL PUT US BACK ON-
ATTRACT. ME OUR COMPLIANCE
DEADLINES WITHOUT A PULLED WITH
WITHHOLDING THE COMMITMENT OF
ENSURING WE STILL MEET OUR GRID
RELIABILITY. FOR THOSE REASONS I
ANSWER I KNOW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING. BACK THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE. SEEN
NONE. BRING UP THE OPPOSITION.
WE A- JOHNSON JONES MR WHY
MISTER MEMBERS GOT WET ON BEHALF
CAL STATE BY TRADES CAL THE WES
STATES OF SHEEP WORKERS
CALIFORNIA COALITION TOLD
EMPLOYEES STATUS ELECTRICAL
WORKERS I ACTUALLY WAS INVOLVED
IN NEGOTIATING THE POLICY AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD DESPITE WHAT
WAS SAID BY THE SUPPORTERS IT
WAS NOT LEGISLATION IT WAS
REGULATION IT STILL IS
REGULATION. WE WERE OBJECTION TO
THIS BILL IT'S VERY POORLY
WRITTEN PUBLIC POLICY. FIRST AND
FOREMOST IT HAS FNDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS THAT ARE NOT
ACCURATE. AND THAT ARE. THERE TO
CREATE- BASICALLY A NARRATIVE.
IT SAYS THAT- HATE SPEECH TO THE
FACT THAT- THERE WERE.
COMMITMENTS MADE AND THAT THEY
WERE DEADLINES IN THIS
REGULATION. MYTH DOESN'T EXIST.
THE POLICY WAS ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED TO PHASE OUT THE OTC
PLANTS VERY CLEARLY IF THE STATE
DID NOT NEED THE POWER FOR
RELIABILITY. LET ME READ FROM
THE POLICY. THE STATE WATER
BOARD RECOGNIZES THE COMPLIANCE
DATES IN THIS POLICY MAY REQUIRE
AMENDMENT BASED ON THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY NO PROMISES
NO COMMITMENTS WE NEED TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON. FUNDAMENTALLY WE
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT INAPPROPRIATELY. AND
I WOULD ARGUE POTENTIALLY
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY DELEGATES
LEGISLATIVE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
AUTHORITY TO AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THAT DOES NOT EXIST IN STATUTE
THE CYCLIST ADVISORY COMMITTEE
IS NOT IN STATUTE IT COULD BE IT
COULD BE WIPED OUT TOMORROW. IT
COULD BE CHANGED IT DOESN'T
EXIST IN STATUTE AND SECONDLY.
THE PRESIDENT OF DELEGATING TO A
LAW TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. THE
ABILITY TO DETERMINE IF A CITED
POWER PLANT SIX CRITICAL TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON SHOULD REMAIN OPEN OR
NOT. IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN AN
INAPPROPRIATE. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE SCOPING PLANS FROM CARB
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA NEED THESE
OTC PLANS PROBABLY THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. OKAY WHAT IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOING TO
MEET OUR POWER DEMANDNEEDS WE
ARE BUYING EVERY NATURAL GAS
PEAKER PLANT AVAILABLE IN THE
NORTHERN HEMISPHERE. WE ARE
LOCATING THEM WHERE. NEXT TO
LOAD NEXT TO FACTORIES
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES AND WHERE
THOSE LOCATED. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BUT NO NO
NO OF THE WEALTHY WHITE ELITIST
COASTAL COMMUNITY COMES FORWARD
BECAUSE A POWER PLANT EXISTS THE
ONLY OPERATES FOR FIVE DAYS OUT
OF THE YEAR AND ONLY DURING PEAK
DEMAND. WE WANT TO WE WHAT WE
WANT TO SHORT CIRCUIT THE
PROCESS UP WE WOULD URGE A NO
VOTE OF THE SYSTEM HAS WORKED
PERFECTLY FINE THE MAJORITY OF
THE O. T. C.'S HAVE BEEN PHASED
OUT. WE URGE AND I'VE A NO VOTE
. YELLED CUT MY INCOME IS SHORT
I'M VERY FOND OF REDONDO BEACH I
MOVED THERE FROM CHICAGO AND I
WAS TEN AND- HAVE THE MOVE BACK
TO CHICAGO SINCE I DID A COUPLE
OF THE POINTS THAT WERE HIT-
FIRST OF ALL THE ONES DOLENJE
DISHES THAT ARGUMENT ABOUT ONCE
YOU COOLEY THAT THAT SHIPS THAT
SAILED I GUESS WAS WRONG
METAPHOR LONG TIME AGO. MOST OF
THE FACILITIES WERE REPOWER- IN
IN THE STATE- THERE HAVE THERE
ARE STILL SEVERAL THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN REPOWERED AND WE'RE
SCHEDULED TO BE RETIRED THAT ALL
OF THAT IS TRUE THE REASON THEY
REMAIN ON OUR LINE IS FOR
RELIABILITY REASONS I THINK
THERE'S GENERAL AGREEMENT WITH
THIS AND SO IF IN FACT THE MARCH
TWENTIETH- SECOND- DEPARTURE
TWENTY TWENTY TO REPORT- THAT MR
MERCER G. COMMENTED ON EARLIER
IS TRUE. THEN THIS BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY BECAUSE THESE PLANS
WILL GO OUT- IN THREE YEARS THE
PROBLEM IS- THE TWO THINGS ONE
WITH THE AMENDED BILL IT TALKS
ABOUT THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
TALKING ABOUT STATEWIDE- LOOK
MATURITY RELIABILITY- IT IS VERY
POTENTIAL- ITS POTENTIAL AND
PROBABLY MORE LIKELY THAT WILL
BE NEEDED FOR LOCAL RELIABILITY
THAT MAY NOT BE THE DOES DECIDE
TO RUN TO STATEWIDE ISSUE- AND
SO. AT ANY RATE WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF BY WAY OF A
RESOLUTION- BECOMING DID THIS
POSITIVE OF DECIDED ORDERED
CONTINUE OPERATION OF- OF-
VARIOUS TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY IN
THIS CASE THE ONCE TO COOLING
UNITS BUT LOOKING AT THIS ON THE
DOWNRANGE TWO SOLAR PLANTS
TRANSMISSION THOSE THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS. SO IT WE WOULD LIKE
TO GET BACK ON TRACK WITH THE
GET IT IS FACILITIES REPLACED
THERE ARE THE END OF THE AS IT
HAS IN ALICE'S POINTS OUT THERE
WAS YOU SEE PROCUREMENTS TO
REPLACE THESE PLANTS
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE BEHIND
SCHEDULE SO I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THE FUTURE OF STYLES I DON'T
WANT TO AWARD AWARDED. MORE TALK
ABOUT THIS SO I'M YOU KNOW WILL
WE'LL SEE WHAT. BUT I WOULD BE
VERY. ABOUT TIMES HANDS OF THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY ONE FORTY THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR JER JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL FOR
THE REASONS BRIEFLY STATED ALSO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. IT ALSO
OPPOSITION. C. NONE. BETTER
MODERATE WITH THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY. YOUR FRIEND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN THERE
UP IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
MANY PARALYZED WITH MONTEREY
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WERE
IN OPPOSITION A. B. TWO ONE FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS WHAT THEY CLL
VOTES WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES MADE UP
WITH THIRTEEN AFFILIATED LOCAL
UNIONS AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DANNY
RIGHT YOU A BUSINESS MANAGER
FRESNO CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY PLUMBERS
PIPE AND REFRIGERATION FETTERS.
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BENITO
PABLO FROM WITH THE LABOR
STATISTICS COUNCIL HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING. OPPOSE IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE. ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY LIFE FOURTEEN MY
NAME IS TIMOTHY JEFFRIES
INTERNATIONAL POLITICAL OF
MAKERS REPRESENTING THE FULL
MARKET NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SPENDING WITH THE STATE BUILDING
SPEAK UP INSTRUCTORS TRUSTED
TRADE COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS DANNY BURKE I'M OF
LOCAL THREE FORTY THREE THE
PERSISTING FETTERS WE'RE JOINING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE THE SIXTY SEVEN
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK THE
BILL THE PROCESS LATER SPOKE
SIXTEEN STANDING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE FIFTY FIVE MEAL AND IS OPEN
. YES THIS IS BILL CHISHOLM WITH
THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS UNION.
SAN FRANCISCO WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU HAVE TO GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT
BEALE I'M REPRESENTING THE
PLUMBER SPEAKERS UP SALMON HILL
COUNTY. AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS SHANE
BOSTON BUSINESS MANAGER OF LOCAL
FORTY FOUR PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS INTEREST. WE STAND
WITH STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF THE B. TWENTY ONE
FORTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
TO GO TO LINE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE BILL WHAT THE
LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT SAN FRANCISCO
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES SUPPOSED TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THIS MESSAGE WHICH I
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU I- I. WOULD
JUST LIKE. TO STATING CLOSING
THAT- YOU KNOW. WE INCLUDED IN
THE LOCAL ADOPTION OF THE
ORDINANCE TO ALLOW FOR SOME
COASTAL. OUR PLANTS LIKE AND
CORPSMAN BERMAN BEACH ORMOND
BEACH. BECAUSE THEY HAVE-
NEGOTIATED FOR THE EXTENSIONS OF
THEIR ONCE THROUGH COOLING
PLANTS BUT ULTIMATELY LIKE
MISTER SMARTY JONES INDICATED
THE SHIP HAS SAILED IN TERMS OF
THE POLICY OF CLOSING DOWN THE
ONCE THROUGH COOLING POWER
PLANTS THE ONLY ISSUE THAT
REMAINS IS THE ENERGY
RELIABILITY. AND WE'VE ADDRESSED
THAT ENERGY RELIABILITY IF SAC
WIS FINDS THAT THE CONTINUATION
OF THE REDONDO BEACH OR ANY
OTHER COASTAL POWER PLANT IS
NECESSARY FOR STATEWIDE INTO ME
LIKE I MEAN STATEWIDE MEANS. B.
HOLE STATE- IF WE WANT TO
CLARIFY TO INCLUDE STATEWIDE AND
LOCAL ENERGY RELIABILITY WERE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE ARE WE WANT TO.
ENFORCE THE DEADLINE THAT WAS
ADOPTED MORE THAN TEN YEARS AGO
TO SHUT DOWN THE ONCE THROUGH
COOLING POWER PLANTS WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF ENERGY
RELIABILITY WITH THE SACK WAS
AMENDMENT. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS THE BUSHES DO
PASSED TO YOU ANY MA'AM
SECRETAY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
IN WITH EMOTION A SECOND SORRY.
SCHUR'S. THIS CALL THE ROLL.
RIVAS FLOOR THE FLOOR NO
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS NO
MATHIS NUMBER TWO G. HI RICH U.
G. I. REYES. SEYARTO NO CEAR
TORONTO STONE WOULD WOOD I. ONE
FIGURES AS FOR VOTE LEAVE IT ON
CALL. THIS OR WHEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT. 0% AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHARMERS AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
WOULD CREATE A SAFE ACCESSIBLE
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIANS TO DROP
OFF THEIR BATTERIES FOR PROPER
DISPOSAL OF BATTERIESARE
BECOMING MORE PREVALENT IN OUR
EVERYDAY LIVES AND THE LACK OF
CONVENIENT DISPOSAL DISPOSAL
OPTIONS IS LEADING TO HIGHER
LEVELS OF TOXIC BATTERIES
ENTERING OUR WASTE STREAM
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SURVEY OF TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA
MARCH TWENTY FACILITIES
EXPERIENCED AT LEAST ONE FIRE
DURING THE PRIOR TWO YEARS OF
WHICH BATTERIES COST 65% WE MUST
DO BETTER WITHOUT DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF BATTERIES
ENTERING CALIFORNIA'S WAY STREAM
WE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY SUFFER
ADDITIONAL FIRES THAT COULD
RESULT IN LOSS OF LIFE. LIGHTS
AND JEOPARDIZE CALIFORNIA'S
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
EMPHASIZE MY COMMITMENT TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE TO WITH
SUPPORT AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KAYLA ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE A
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY BASED
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND RESIDENCES AND ELEVEN
THOUSAND BUSINESSES. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE EXPERIENCED FIRST
HAND THE CATASTROPHIC EFFECTS OF
A LITHIUM ION BATTERY INDUCED
FIRE AT A RECYCLING CENTER HE
COMPLETELY DEVASTATED OUR
FACILITIES SHUTTING US DOWN FOR
NINETY DAYS AND CAUSING EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES. IT TOOK APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR TO FULLY REPAIR EVERYTHING
PRIOR TO THE FIRE WE HAD ONE
INSURANCE PROVIDER NOW WE NEED
SEVEN TO ABOUT THE SAME KIND OF
COVERAGE INSURANCE RIDERS ARE
FINDING IT TOO RISKY TO COVER
FACILITIES LIKE OURS AFTER THE
EXCESSIVE DAMAGES IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES TO REMOVE
BATTERIES ARE WAY STREAM BUT
LAST YEAR ALONE WE SUFFERED
TWELVE FIRES BETWEEN OUR
MATERIAL COVERS FACILITY AND
TRANSFER STATION TEN OF THEM
COULD BE ATTRIBUTED TO LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES. ANY ONE OF THESE
FIRES COULD GROW INTO A FIRE
LIKE THE ONE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND ANOTHER MAJOR FIRE COULD
CAUSE US TO LOSE OUR INSURANCE
COMPLETELY. THESE BATTERIES
THREATEN THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
PUBLICLY FUNDED WASTE COLLECTION
AND RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THESE FIRES POSE A SAFETY HAZARD%
TO OUR WORKERS THIS ISSUE IS
COMMON AT MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES ACROSS THE NATION AND
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT NEEDS A
SOLUTION NOW AS LITHIUM ION
BATTERIE ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE COMMON IN EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
IS CRITICAL TO DIVERTING
BATTERIES AND PRODUCTS IN THE
WASTE STREAM TO PROTECT OUR
WORKERS OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
JASON SMALL TERM HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS GEORGIA COUNCIL ONE OF
THE TWO CO SPONSORS OF THE
MEASURE I WANNA BE CLEAR FROM
THE OUTSET THAT THIS BILL ISN'T
ABOUT DEMONIZING ANY SPECIFIC
PRODUCT OR PRODUCT CATEGORY- AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY IS SIMPLY A
RECOGNITION THAT SOME PRODUCTS
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON THE
SAFETY- AND RESILIENCY OF OUR
SOLID WASTE AND RECYCLING
SYSTEM- AND THE PRODUCER SHOULD
SHARE. IN SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MITIGATING
THOSE IMPACTS- THE BILL REQUIRES
PRODUCERS TO OF LOOSE BATTERIES
AND BATTERY EMBEDDED PRODUCTS TO
ESTABLISH AN EXTENDED PRODUCT
THAT PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAM FOR THEIR PRODUCTS-
PRIOR VERSIONS OF THE BILL HAD
LEASED BATTERIES AND BATTERY
EMBEDDED PRODUCTS IN THE SAME
PROGRAM THIS BILL SEPARATES THEM
INTO TWO DISTINCT PROGRAMS- THAT
ALLOWS US TO YOU- ESSENTIALLY-
CONSTRUCT DIFFERENT PROGRAMMATIC
ELEMENTS FOR EACH PRODUCT
CATEGORY THAT WORK BEST FOR-
THAT PRODUCT IN THE IN THE
PRODUCERS- BUT THE STRUCTURE OF
TWENTY FOUR FORTY IS PRETTY
CONSISTENT- WITH RECENTLY PASSED
A RICHER PROGRAMS THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH THIS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES. SO THE BILL'S
ESSENTIALLY GONNA REQUIRE
PRODUCERS TO DESIGN FUND AND
IMPLEMENT A TAKE BACK AND
RECYCLING PROGRAM THAT'S GOING
TO CONTAIN A PLAN APPROVAL
PROCESS THAT IT AGAIN IS PRETTY
SIMILAR TO WHAT'S BEEN DONE WITH
OTHER EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAMS- IT HAS
CLEAR REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
COLLECTION NETWORK IT'S GOTTEN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE SO WHETHER
STAKEHOLDERS CAN CHIME AND- AND
PROVIDE INPUT ON THE PLAN- DOES
CREATE AN OBLIGATION ON SOME
RETAIL TO TAKE BACK BATTERIES
AND SOME- BATTERY AND BETTER
PRODUCTS AND IT DOES HAVE STRONG
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE DIVERSE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE WORKING
CONSTRUCTIVELY- ON THIS BILL-
SOLUTIONS ORIENTED I THINK
THAT'S THE THEME FOR THE GROUP-
ENTIRELY- AND THERE ARE SOME
DETAILS LEFT TO BE WORKED OUT
BUT I'M CONFIDENT- IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AND HER
LEADERSHIP AND I'M NOT CONFIDENT
IN THE GROUP IN THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAVE GOING AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. THE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX. ABOUT A
MILE AND A HALF OF C. ARE IN OUR
IN SUPPORT. LOCAL KOREAN
REPRESENT CALIFORNIANS WASTE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTHDAY
MCCONNELL WITH LIKE A CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. MICHAEL DAFT
WITH THE PRAM KAYLEE ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JOHN KENNEDY ON
BEHALF OF RC RC AND SEE SECOND
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HE WANTED
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
. TO AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
OPPOSITION. MISTER MEMBERS FEEL
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE FOR THE
REASONS STATED IN OUR LETTER
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE OTHER SPONSORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION. SAY NOT ONLY TO THE
PHONE LINES AT A MODERATOR
ANYONE TO SUPPORT AND OPT FOR
OPPOSITION AB. TWENTY FOUR
FORTY. YOUR FRIEND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND
THEN THEY OFFER ANY SUPPORT
THEIR OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO
THE RIGHT EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PERSONALLY IT ALSO
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL
ALAMEDA STOP WAIT. IN THE
WESTERN COSTA RICA MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
THERE ARE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS SORT OF. SO
IN THIS BILL AND ENVISIONS THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE THE RETAILERS
BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR THE-
RECYCLING OF THE BATTERIES. HOW
DO WE GET CONSUMERS ISN'T THAT'S
WHERE THAT'S WHERE THE ISSUE
HAPPENS BECAUSE WE BURNED UP I
THINK FOR TRASH TRUCKS IN THE
LAST. LAST FEW BY A COUPLE
MONTHS HERE- PROBABLY FROM THIS
. CONSUMERS AND THEY HAVE SOME
WE HAVE PLAYED PLENTY OF PLACES
RIGHT NOW- LOWE'S HOME DEPOT
EVERYWHERE THEY TAKE BACK
BATTERIES BUT WE CAN'T GET
PEOPLE. TO TAKE HIM BACK SO HOW
DO WE INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE. TO
TAKE THESE BATTERIES AND USE THE
ONES WE ALREADY HAVE. A CARD
THAT WITHOUT TURNING INTO A
BECAUSE THE FINES ON HERE HUGE.
FOR THE OTHERS AND I AM NOT
QUITE SURE HOW THEY GET- WITH
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING
WILL BE FOLDED INTO THIS PROGRAM
BUT THE CORNERSTONE OF THAT ANY
RECYCLING PROGRAMS EDUCATION AND
B. THE PRODUCERS. OF WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT EDUCATION
AND WHETHER IT'S- TV OR ON THE
INTERNET OR- NOTES WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR TRASH. OF IT IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT WORKING BECAUSE OF
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE PLACES THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT DIET WITH. WE KNOW
ALMOST- AT LEAST I HAVE A ZIPLOC
BAG FILLED WITH BATTERIES AND
ALMOST EVERYBODY I KNOW HAS AZIPLOC BAG FILLED WITH BATTERIES
IN THEIR DRAWERS AND THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHERE TO GET RID OF
THOSE BATTERIES SO WHAT WE NEED
TO MAKE THESE. PLACES WERE
BATTERIES CAN BE RETURNED WERE
UBIQUITOUS AND WE NEED TO DO A
VERY ROBUST EDUCATION PROGRAM.
I'M SURE YOU. KNOW THAT THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT I WOULD SAY AS WELL
I THINK EDUCATION IS GOING TO BE
CORNERSTONE BUT I THINK
CONVENIENCE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THIS PROGRAM AND
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE STATE
CURRENTLY LACKS. YEAH THE
CONVENIENCE PART OF IT BECAUSE
THAT SEEMS TO BE THAT THAT
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT
EVERYBODY HAS WITH ALL OF THIS
IS YOU KNOW EVEN RECYCLING IN
GENERAL IS IF IT'S TOO DIFFICULT
MATT AND THEN WE CAN GET PEOPLE
TO DO AND PUNISHING THE
COMPANIES DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MAKE THOSE PEOPLE DO IT ANY
BETTER I DO WANT TO SAY WE ARE
WE HAVE HAD EVERY- EVERY PERSON
IN THE CONVERSATION WE ARE
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
SHAREHOLDER HAS SAY ON HOW WE
ARE GOING TO MAKE THIS WORK AND
USE YOU DON'T SEE ANY. ROBUST
OPPOSITION HERE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW WE ARE SOLUTIONS ORIENTED
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS WORKS FOR EVERYBODY RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THE SERVER THANK YOU. THIS IS-
THEY ANY BURKE CALLING MR
SCHROEDER BRINGS UP A GOOD POINT
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO
RECYCLING IT IS THE EDUCATION.
WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO IS WHAT IS
THE PARTNERSHIP AND WHO PAYS FOR
THAT WHO PAYS FOR THE EDUCATION
DO YOU HAVE THE STATE TO IT DO
YOU HAVE THE COMPANIES DO IT. DO
YOU KNOW. DO YOU HAVE A
COMBINATION. I THINK YOU'RE
TRYING TO BRING EVERYBODY TO THE
TABLE YOU'RE TRYING TO WORK THAT
OUT WHERE THERE IS GOOD
CORPORATE SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
HAPPENING. IN TAKING PLACE- BUT
IN A FAIR AND JUST WAY. IN WE
HAVE TO FIGURE SOMETHING OUT. IN
THIS KIND OF THE BEST THING ON
THE TABLE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE
CANNOT CONTINUE THE WAY THAT WE
ARE GOING- AND SOMETHING HAS TO
BE DONE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS. MISTER WOULD YES
WELL THANK YOU- MR WENT FO
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED- I THINK
ANYBODY REALLY ANTICIPATED
SPECIALLY WITH LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES IF THEY BECOME
SIGNIFICANT FIRE HAZARD THAT
THEY HAVE- SO I DON'T SEE A
SOLUTION OTHER THAN RECYCLING
THEM AND COLLECTING THEM AND-
AND JUST IN GENERAL BATTERIES
WHETHER LITHIUM LITHIUM ION OR
NOT CREATE A HUGE CHALLENGE FOR
US TO FIND A WAY TO GET RID OF
THEM OR GET THEM BACK TO
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY CAN BE
RECYCLED SO. HAPPENS FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY HAVE A TO BE ADDED AS
A COOPER THANKS MISTER RIGHT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- I CLEARLY
NEED TO A BAGGIE OF HATTERAS
HEMP SUPER CONVICTED ON THAT
RIGHT NOW SO MY BAD- IT IS
INTERESTING THAT INITIALLY BILL
AND I THINK FOR OUR OUR WASTE
HANDLERS IT IS SUPER IMPORTANT I
ALSO KNOW YOU'RE VERY. CLOSE
WITH THE OPPOSITION WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM SO
PLEASE IN CONCORD YOU TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT OFFICE
SUPPORTING AS WELL SO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND. MASSACRE
CRYSTAL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS
FLORA FLORA AYE BOERNER HORVATH
HI BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS HI
MATHIS I REFERRED. TO G.
MURATSUCHI I. REYES. SAY NOW.
SIX AND NUMBER THIRTY STONE.
WOOD WOOD I THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIRTY MEMBERS THANK YOU.
BELIEVE IT OR CALL. ALL RIGHT.
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS
BECAUSE SECULAR SECOND RIGHT.
MADAM SPEAKER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
. ALL RIVAS FLORA FLORA I'VE
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I FRIEDMAN ARSIA GARCIA I MATHIS
. MATHIS HI WHERE TO CHANGE RATE
C. GI REYES. SEYARTO SEYARTO AYE
STONE WOOD. WHEN I FOR THE FOR
THE RECORD WOULD YOU MIND
READING OUT THE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JUST FOR
EVERYONE- ITEMS ARE EIGHTY
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT KALRA.
IN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
STOCK. HI SIMONE GARCIA WE'RE
GOING TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY NINE ALSO KNOWN AS THE
NATURAL CARBON SEQUESTRATION A
RESILIENCE ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO CALLS FOR THE SEQUESTRATION
OF SIXTY MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CARBON BY TWENTY THIRTY ON
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. THIS
BILL ALSO CALLS FOR AN INCREASE
IN SEQUESTRATION TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION METRIC TONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. TO PUT THIS INTO
PERSPECTIVE SIXTY MILLION METRIC
TONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE IS
EQUIVALENT TO THE YEARLY CARBON
EMISSIONS ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION
CARS. THIS IS AN AMBITIOUS YET
ACHIEVABLE TARGET I CAN TURN
CLIMATE GOALS AND THE ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- AND- IN
LINE WITH THE FACT THAT ARE
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS ARE
ONE OF THE PILLARS OF THE
STATE'S CLIMATE STRATEGY.
INVESTING IN PROVEN COST
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
COMPOSTING FOOD WASTE AND A
PLANE TO SOIL FOR PLANTING COVER
CROPS URBAN TREE PLANTING AND
HABITAT RESTORATION FROM CAN
HELP CALIFORNIA BECOME A GLOBAL
MODEL. IS A WIN WIN FOR NATURAL
CARBON SEQUESTRATION. THIS
APPROACH IS NOT ONLY SEQUESTER
CARBON BUT IMPROVE WATER
SECURITY AND RESILIENCE TO
DROUGHT REDUCE POLLUTION
ENHANCED BY THE VARSITY. AND
HELP BOTH RURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES ADAPT TO CLIMATE
IMPACTS. ACHIEVING THIS GOAL
WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT FORWARD
THINKING POLICIES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND COORDINATED
ACTION WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
GROUND. BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
BENEFITS FROM INVESTING CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS TODAY FAR OUTWEIGH THE
COST OF INACTION DOWN THE ROAD.
THE LAST THING I WILL ADD IS
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROPOSALS ON TECHNOLOGY MATT
THAT'S REMOVING CARVE AND BETTY
ARE UNPROVEN AND COSTLY OFTEN. I
AS AN ENERGY INTENSIVE AND YET
NOT SCALABLE BUT NATURAL WORKING
LANDS NATURAL CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IS AFFORDABLE
READILY DEPLOYABLE SCALABLE
SCALEABLE SCALABLE AND JUST. IT
ALSO DELIVERS A BROAD SUITE OF
BENEFITS BEYOND CLIMATE WATER
SECURITY AIR AND WATER QUALITY
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE AND
BIODIVERSITY- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY S. ELLIE
COLIN WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER.
IN CAMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH YES SO- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR RIVAS IS NOT
HERE EVERYONE ON THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME'S ELLIE COHEN CEO OF THE
CLIMATE CENTER I'M HONORED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY NINE WHICH WILL SET IN
STATUTE URGENTLY NEEDED STATE
GOALS FOR NATURALLY. REMOVING
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE.
RECENT U. N. CLIMATE SCIENCE
REPORTS ARE CLEAR THE WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY TO SECURE A LIVABLE
FUTURE IS QUICKLY CLOSING NO
TEMPERATURE RISE IS SAFE FOR THE
LATEST SITES UNLESS WE ACT
BOLDLY TODAY. CALIFORNIA WILL BE
INCREASINGLY DEVASTATED BY
GREATER EXTREMES INCLUDING
SEVERE HEAT AND DROUGHT THAT
ALREADY THREATEN OUR FORESTS AND
COMMUNITIES AND WILL THREATEN
THE VIABILITY OF MANY OF OUR
CROPS AS EARLY AS TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. WE MUST CUT FOSSIL FUEL
USE IN HALF BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
BEGIN REMOVING CARBON POLLUTION
WE'VE ALREADY PUT IN THE
ATMOSPHERE TO HAVE A SHOT AT
SECURING A STABLE CLIMATE. TO
REMOVE CATHOLIC BUT PASS CARBON
POLLUTION THE STATE MUST SCALE
UP NATURAL CARBON SEQUESTRATION
PRACTICES LIKE COMPOSTING FOOD
WASTE AND APPLYING THOSE TO
SOILS PLAN COVER CROPS GREENING
URBAN AREAS AND RESTORING
HABITAT. WIN WIN OUTCOMES WILL
INCREASE WATER AND FOOD SECURITY
REDUCE POLLUTION AND HEAT
IMPACTS PROTECT FARMWORKERS
CREATE NEW JOBS AND HELP US
ADAPT TO WORSENING CLIMATE
IMPACTS. CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE TECHNOLOGY IS SOMETIMES
CONFUSED WITH REMOVING CARBON
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. CCS WORKS
AT THE SMOKESTACK OR THE POINT
SOURCE. IT'S BEEN USED FOR
DECADES REPEATEDLY FOUND TO BE
INEFFECTIVE EXPENSIVE AND
POLLUTING ESPECIALLY TO
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IT'S ALMOST ALWAYS USED TO
PRODUCE MORE FOSSIL FUELS WE
ALSO CANNOT RELY ON
TECHNOLOGICAL DIRECT AIR CAPTURE
WHICH IS STILL IN ITS INFANCY
AND NOT YET SCALABLE. ONLY
NATURAL CARBON REMOVAL PROVEN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND AND JUST
CAN COST EFFECTIVELY DRAW DOWN
PAST CARBON EMISSIONS AT SCALE
STARTING THIS DECADE WITH
MULTIPLE BENEFITS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES ENVIRONMENT AND
ECONOMY. AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE IS SUPPORTED BY SIXTY SIX
ORGANIZATIONS WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE NATURAL CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND RESILIENCE ACT
AN ESSENTIAL STEP TOWARD
SECURING A VIBRANT HEALTHY
CLIMATE SAY FUTURE FOR ALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. GOING TO
THE POLLS WITH KAREN FOR. HI MY
NAME IS KAREN BERGER AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESEARCH PUBLICATIONS AFFECT. I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND- THE CORDON BELT.
THERE ARE NINETY FIVE REFER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THE INTERSECTION
OF NATURAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
AND RESILIENT. AGRICULTURE
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS AND
COMMUNITIES. ARE TODAY'S PROVIDE
ON THE GROUND SUPPORT COMMUNITY
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT ARE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT CARBON MARK
PRACTICES. AND BUILD RESILIENCE
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDING SUPPORT TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS IMPLEMENTING WELL
HEALTH AND KIND OF. PRACTICES
WHAT LED RESTORATION PROJECT.
PROTECTING NATIVE FIFTIETH AND
ARE COVERING THEIR HABITAT AND
HELPING LANDOWNERS AND FORESTED
AREAS IN THEIR PROPERTIES FOR
HEALTH AND FIRE SAFETY. WELL
THERE ARE MANY APPLE WHEN. THAT
HELP BUT THE CARBON I'M GONNA
FOCUS ON A OF AN ACT ACT. THE
CLUSTER CARBON THE BILL. FIBER
CROPPING TILL REDUCE STILL MOLD
. COMPOST THE CASE THEN AND-
PLAN ALL GET INCREASED ABILITY
OF THE CLAY ADDITIONAL CARBON.
BIRDS ARE IN MANY CASES THE FACT
THAT CAN ACTUALLY FARM AND
RANCHERS NINETY. COSTS FOR LIKE
THREE. TELLING BECAUSE AND GOT.
NOTHING NOTHING THE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS THE END. THAT YOU IN.
ARCADIS OTHER AT THE- AND-
CARBON CYCLE IN THE TWO FIFTY AM
AND NOT THREE THIRTY. SERVICE
NRPS.
YEAH THAT THEY CAN MAKE AN
EFFORT THAT FARMERS AND RANCHERS
CAN MAKE AN EDUCATED DECISION
ABOUT THEIR PRACTICE FEATURES.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS THE
RPG'S OF AN ENTRANCE ARMOR IS
GENERATING INTEREST AND WRITING
CARTON FONG PLAN. AND I THINK
HE'S A COMPLICATED COMPLETED
PLAN FOR A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
EVERY SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND TOTAL
ACRES. THAT IF AT ALL
INFORMATION AT ALL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CLUSTER
ONE POINT. SEVEN MILLION TIMES A
PART OF. HARBIN I. AT HERE AT
ONE EIGHT. THIRTY HAVE A HOW
PLANS IN PROGRESS ALONG LATE
NIGHT LATE FOR PRETTY SUPPORT.
ONCE THE FARM RANCHER FIGHT THEM
FOR THE NEW PRACTICES NEED HELP
KNOWING HOW TO APPLY THE FACT
THAT THE THERE'S THE- PROPERTY.
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANYTHING IN
THE PRODUCT OF OTHER. AND ONE OF
THE WALK THROUGH THE- IF DON'T
GO EXPECTED THE NEW SOMEONE HELP
AND GUIDE THEM IN THE IT UP. RT
ARE THERE TO HELP THEM THROUGH
EACH STEP OF THE PRACTICES COULD
BE IF THE FACT. PARTNER BUT
SUPPORT CURRENT UNDER. AND UNDER
A VEIL OF BUT IT'S A CRITICAL
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENT. BUT AND THE
GOAL. OF CARBON. EIGHTY TWENTY
SIX FORTY NINE BUT INSTEAD OF
NEXT IMPLEMENTATION OF. I'M WITH
THE COURT R. THESE AT THE THAT
HELP FARMERS RANCHERS COMMUNITY
ACROSS THE STATE. AND BEING ABLE
A FACT SUPPORT IN IMPLEMENTING
PRACTICES. AT TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE WILL PUSH THE STATE BAR
WRITTEN ARE FIGHTING FIND
CHANGE. BUILD RESILIENCE WITH
IMPACT WELL PROVIDING A NUMBER
CODE BENEFIT THE ENVIRONMENT
UNITY. AND FOR ALL OF REASONS
THERE BE ON THE OF OUR MEMBER
DEFECT URGING I ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO COMMUTER
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT. OF AB TWO
SIX NINE. DAVID AUGUST PLEASE.
GOOD MR CHAIRMAN- THAT'S WHERE
LODGE A THE CLIENTS BUT I CAN
ASKING. ME TO THE FOLLOWING
ORGANS. SACRAMENTO CONTRA TO.
THAT'S GOING TO HELP CITIES
COMMITTEE TO- COMPLETE THE
REFUGE. COMMUNITY WATER CENTER
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CENTER OF SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR
RACE PARTY ENVIRONMENT AND CIVIC
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU. LOCAL
KOREAN REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IT SUPPORT. ABOUT
A MILE AND A HALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND IN SUPPORT. THE MELISSA
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HELLO WE HAVE TO TREAT
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. REBECCA
MARKETS REPRESENTING ONE OF THE
BILL'S CO SPONSORS CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IT WAS ALSO STE ANYONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT SCENE NINE ONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
. COME ON UP. SEEING NONE
MATAMATA WE GO TO THE PHONES FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT ONE MAN
ZERO. KAMALA VOTE JULY NUMBER
FORTY TWO THREE WELL I HAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN FOREST COUNCIL
AND WILDLANDS CONSERVANCY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL. I THANK
YOU MY NUMBER NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU CREATIVELY ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU REGARDS
LEVINE NUMBER NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER HEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE PEW CHARITABLE
TRUSTS AND THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER NINETY
THREE SO I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH
FOR LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE HAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO ON
BEHALF OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YEAH. THANK YOU WE WERE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU- MY
NAME'S FRANCIS LEE AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
CHAPTER. PROJECT CHAPTER AND-
THE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
REPORTER LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS HEIDI
HARMON FORMER MAYOR OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND NOW WITH LED SCREEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JANET GEHRY ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
MISTER CARE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SCENE NINE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
RIGHT THERE IS A MOTION AS
AMENDED- THE PAST HAS BEEN TO
APPROPRIATIONS. HE DID ACCEPT
THE MINISTRY I'M SORRY TO HEAR
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEDICAID IF THE FEDERAL. RIVAS
FLOOR NO FLOOR NO
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA. GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MURATSUCHI. REYES SEYARTO.
SEYARTO STONE WOOD WOOD I. BILLS
THROUGH ITS LEAVE IT OPEN. RIGHT
MISTER MERRETT MYSTERY THIS.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES GREAT CIVIL THIS
AFTERNOON AS LEGISLATION- WHO'S
PRESENT THIS AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FOUR FOUR TWO HOW MUCH
IS LEGISLATION THAT SEEKS TO
CLEARLY DEFINE CLIMATE CHANGE AS
A HAZARD UNDER STATE LAW NO
ADDED CLIMATE CHANGE TO THE
DEFINITION OF DISASTER THE
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT WILL ENABLE US TO BETTER
INTEGRATION OF CLIMATE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION
PLANNING AT BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS. CURRENT LAW IS A
CONSISTENT INCONSISTENT AS TO
WHETHER CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
HAZARD UNTO ITSELF OR SIMPLY A
MODIFIER OF EXISTING HAS LIKE A
FIRES AND FLOODS YOU KNOW THIS
CHANGE WOULD CLARIFY THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ITSELF A
HAZARD. WELL THEY HAD TO FIGHT
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR STATE
AND LOCAL TO TAKE A MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO REDUCING
CLIMATE RISK RATHER THAN
TACKLING CLIMATE IMPACTS ONE AT
A TIME- THIS APPROACH COULD
INCLUDE NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS.
SOME SOLUTIONS THAT PROVIDE
MULTIPLE ADAPTATION BENEFITS
WILL ALSO SEQUESTERING CARBON-
THIS LEGISLATION COULD ALSO OPEN
UP NEW DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
FUNDING THROUGH CAL- YES AND
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ULTIMATELY CLIMATE CHANGES MANY
IMPACTS OR THE GREAT HAZARD OF
OUR TIME AS MANY OF US. I WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE- AND THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
INCREASE THEIR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND A MORE HOLISTIC
WAY NOW WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON
TESTIFY IS LOOK IT TOOK IS. A
FREE REX ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU MR. THE
REMOTE. THANKS VERY MUCH I MISS
CHAIR MATT. LUCAS FOR TIME HAVE
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. AS A OF
OUR READ SAID THE AB FORTY
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO WOULD
ELEVATE INCENTIVIZE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS THAT REDUCE. EMISSIONS
AND RISK AND COULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT THESE
ACTIVITIES. THAT MANY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND STATE AGENCIES
ALREADY RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF INTEGRATING THEIR MITIGATION
ADAPTATION EFFORTS- AND WE-
THINK THAT THE PROPOSED CHANGE
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO IS IN
LINE WITH THIS GROWING TREND.
AMONG STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING COUNTY
SANTA CRUZ CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. THAT ALREADY HAVE
DONE THIS AND WOULD ENCOURAGE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE
COULD LEAD TO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND REALLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE COMMUTER AND SO. OF A.
TWENTY FOUR FOUR TWO. ROGER
DICKINSON FOR CIVIC WELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. C. NINE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO. CNN MADAM
MODERATOR COPEPOD LINES FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY TWO. WE HAVE SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO. THE PARKING OPPOSITION ONE
IN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY ONE WALNUT. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIM DELFINO ON THE
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU REMARKABLE
TIMELINE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE SO I HAD. SPORTS NUMBER
SIXTY NINE. WE CAN MOVE ON. OKAY
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR WOOD I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE OFFER
BRING THE BILL FORWARD- LET'S
SEE I WAS COOPERATING TO GREAT
IDEA THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. NONE
OF US RIVAS WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECT THAT'S WHAT I VOTE
MISTER ROGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS AS A
CRITICAL RIVAS. FLORA FLORIDA
BODINE'S. HI FURTHERMORE I.
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS. NUMBER
TWO. REYES SO. THEY ARE NO STONE
WOULD WITH I. THE BILL AS WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN. WE DO HAVE
THREE MORE MA'AM THAT WORK
WAITING- UNTIL THEN. WE CAN GO
THROUGH THAT ON WHICH I COULD.
THE MOST. OF COURSE. RIGHT RIGHT. RIGHT NOW FORTY FOUR.
THE STAFF.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS. LARA AYE
FLORA AYE BOERNER HORVATH HAI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI REYES SEYARTO HI C.
A. R. TO AYE STONE WOULD. WOOD I
. YEAH BILLS BY WAS LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR MEMBERS AT ALL. TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY THAT MOVED. NOT YET
MAYBE MOVE WITH TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY PLEASE. THE MOTION IS DUE
FOR AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
RIVAS FLORA NO FLOOR NO
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I FRIEDMAN GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MURATSUCHI.
REYES SEYARTO SEYARTO NO STONE
WHAT WOULD I. BLUSTERY WITH
LEVODOPA FOR MEMBERS AT ALL.
THAT'S. YEAH THIS ON ALL. YEAH
WHAT WE WANT. YEAH. TWENTY FIVE.
SO. ACTUALLY I THINK THIS. OR OR
OR- YEAH. PURSUED YES THEY JUST. THE OTHER STATES YEAH. SIX
YEAH. GO AHEAD RESEARCH AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT FOR SOMEONE OVER
CUNNINGHAM AB TWENTY FIVE SEVEN
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO INCLUDE CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION. AND
THEIR BIANNUAL INTEGRATION
KENNEDY POLICY REPORT WHEN
REVIEWING YOUR AMBITION
POLLUTION CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES
FOR ENERGY PLANTS IN HERE TO
PRESENTED OFFERING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND- MADAM CHAIR-
VIRTUAL WORLDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION THE COALITION IS A
BUSINESS LABOR ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT CCS
TECHNOLOGIES ARE PART OF THE
EFFORT IN CALIFORNIA- I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR- ALL OF THE EXPERT
ANALYSIS- HAS INDICATED THAT A
SUITE OF APPROACHES TO REDUCING
EMISSIONS ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED- INCLUDING- BOTH
ENGINEERED AND- NATURAL CARBON.
SEQUESTRATION TECHNOLOGIES SO-
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER- SOME OF
YOU MAY RECALL- WHAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE IS- A NUMBER OF
INDUSTRIES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM APPLICATION OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE SOME OF THE
BEST GEOLOGY IN THE WORLD- TO
STORE PERMANENTLY AND SAFELY-
ADMISSIONS- BUT WHAT WE NEED IS
A POLICY FRAMEWORK THAT IS GONNA
ENABLE THE STATE TO BENEFIT-
FROM THE SWEET OF- CCS
TECHNOLOGIES- AND BY
INCORPORATING- AN EVALUATION OF
C. C. U. S. AND TO THE I PAPER.
OBVIOUSLY THAT GIVES US AN
IMPORTANT TOOL- IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE PLANNING- FROM AN ENERGY
STANDPOINT TO INCORPORATE C. C.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
NOT PRESENTING THE BILL- AND.
WOULD CERTAINLY URGENT ABOUT.
LOOK AT THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY MR MATHIS- AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR ARE AT THE AUTHOR IS
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES OKAY THANK GOT A
SECOND BY MISS- FOR YES OR NO
HARD BACK TO THE ONE MESS IT UP
- OF THAT ACCORDING TO BE-
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMIT JERRY SMITH
YOU'RE GOING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO SUPPORT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUGGESTING
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE
CATEGORIZATION OF CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IS AN AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL TECHNOLOGY AND WITH THAT
CHANGE OF THE AUTHOR IS MAKING
THAT CHANGE WILL BE REASSESSING
OUR POSITION- SO WANTED TO VOICE
THAT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. HEARING TO MOVE ON TO
THE PHONES IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT ARE ONLY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION PLEASE.
MODERATOR YOUR INPUT YEAH SURE
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT IT IS ONE NINE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE LINE. ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. MADAM
CHAIR I DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP AS OF RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEN NONE THE
CHAIR THE SEVENTH TO PASS- WITH
AMENDMENTS- CULTURAL PLEASE TELL
TWENTY ONE PLUS THAT'S WHAT I'VE
BEEN THINKING. OKAY MOTION IS
THE BEST AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS REVERSE FLORA.
FLORA AYE BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN
GARCIA NOBODY CRISTINA PRODUCE
MATHIS HI MATHIS I MURATSUCHI
REYES SEYARTO HI C. R. TO AYE
STONE. WOOD WOOD HI WHICH BILL.
CUNNINGHAM I DON'T. TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT YES YEAH. YOU CAN
GO STONE NO. THE BILL HAS BY
BOTH WILL KEEP THE ROAD OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WOULD IS
ASSET FOR THE MEMBERS I HAVE
BILLS AND NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE COME AND
PRESENT WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS
LEFT. UNTIL THEN I WILL JUST GO
TO THE FULL.
THREE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO TO
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
ONE GARCIA. MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS. ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN I STILL C. K.
C. A. R. NO SAY OUR TURN NOW
STONE STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE
BILL HAS SUCCESSFULLY BEEN ON
CALL. RELIVE THE CALL ADAM FOR
AB TWENTY THIRTY SIX GARCIA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN. GARCIA THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER. FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. IT IS
GARCIA I SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO
STONE. STONE I WOULD. WHAT I. I
CAN FOR. SO. DURING THE. TWENTY
SO HERE SO IT. OKAY WE LOOK ON
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
ARE FRIEDMAN GARCIA. CONTACT
I'VE NORTH FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE. GARCIA I
SEYARTO THEY ARE TO KNOW STONE
RIGHT STONE I WOULD. WOOD I.
DIGITAL THAT THE BILL HAS A WILL
LEAVE IT ON CALL INTREPID ABSENT
MEMBERS OUT ON. OVERLOOK THE
CALL ITEM SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX GARCIA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN. SEYARTO NUMBER
HERE TO NOT LOADING. WOOD WOOD
HI. THE BILL WAS ABLE TO LEAVE
IT OPEN. OKAY. IT WOULD HELP
ITEM NINE TWENTY FOUR FORTY.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY IRWIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN. REYES REYES I STONE
STONE I. THE BILL AS IT WAS
LEAVING ON CALL. DR QUIRK IF
YOU'RE READY TO PRESENT. I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. SECOND. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS THANK
SET THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
MEASURE AND CONTROL BENZENE
EMISSIONS TO ALLOW DISTRICTS TO
APPLY MORE STRINGENT TECHNOLOGY
STANDARDS. PROVIDED THAT THE
DISTRICT REGULATIONS ARE
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE. BOB.
MOBILE FUELING THIS SERVICE THAT
IS RAPIDLY EMERGED THROUGH START
UPS IN RECENT YEARS AN INDUSTRY
THAT STATE AND LOCAL REGULATIONS
HAVE. NOT CAUGHT UP WITH YET.
CURRENTLY MANY HERE DISTRICTS
CHOIRS CERTAIN. PAPER RECOVERY
SYSTEM THAT ONLY APPLIES TO
CONVENTIONAL GAS STATIONS AND
THEREFORE PROHIBITS RETAIL
MOBILE FUELING. FURTHER ALSO
MOBILE VIEWERS USE CERTIFIED
VAPOR RECOVERY SYSTEMS. THERE
ARE MANY OTHERS THAT USE
STANDARD PICKUP TRUCKS. IN
OPERATE ON REGULATED DUE TO
ACTIVATED DISTRICT RULES. MOBILE
FEELING NUTRIA'S ALREADY
EXPANDED. IN AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE INITIATES UP TO DATE
LOCAL REGULATIONS FOR THE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THIS INDUSTRY
. THIS BILL INITIATES HIGH
CONSISTENT STANDARDS. FOR MOBILE
FUELING EQUIPMENT AND ENSURES
THAT OPERATIONS MEET OR EXCEED
STATE STANDARDS FOR MISSION
CONTROL. SPECIFIES THAT AIR
DISTRICTS MAY IMPOSE STRICTER
STANDARDS ACCORDING TO
REGIONALES BY LIMITING THE TOTAL
OUTPUT OF FUEL AND RESTRICTING
FIELDING LOCATION. AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE DOES NOT APPLY
THE AIR DISTRICT THAT ESTABLISH
THEIR OWN MOBILE FEELY PERMIT
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE MOBILE
FUELING FROM PERMITTING. BEFORE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
MANY MEMBERS WILL EXTEND THIS
DEADLINE FURTHER TO JANUARY. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS BILL
ALLOWS DISTRICTS THE OPTION TO
ESTABLISH YOUR OWN EQUIPMENT
STANDARDS ACCORDING TO DISTRICTS
INTERPRETATION OF BEST AVAILABLE
CONTROL TECHNOLOGY. TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE HAS SUPPORT FROM THE
HYDROGEN COALITION- DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND FIRE SAFETY
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE. WITH ME
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OUR CHAU
OAK PARK- FROM POSTER FUELS
MISTER HAYES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
THE COALITION FOR SMART FUELING
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOE COME
ON UP LET ME TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
. AND LISA YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
APIECE WE CAN MOVE THAT CHAIR
WHERE WE NEED TO. RELEASE A-
THAT'S ANOTHER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FLORA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOSEPH A POCKET- AND I AM THE
CHIEF POLICY OFFICER FOR
BREWSTER A MOBILE ENERGY
DELIVERY COMPANY AND A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL BEFORE YOU. MOBILE
FEELING IS A NEW INDUSTRY THAT
WAS BASED ON A SIMPLE IDEA. WHAT
IF YOU'LL COULD BE DELIVERED
STRAIGHT TO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT MOST LIKELY EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
FOR WHOM ACCESS TO GAS STATIONS
IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. WELL THE
FEELING IS THE GREENEST WAY TO
DELIVER FUEL BECAUSE IT REDUCES
SPILLAGE SIGNIFICANTLY. REDUCES
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
EMISSIONS BY BEING ABLE TO FUEL
MORE THAN A HUNDRED VEHICLES
WITH JUST ONE TANKER- AND IT
REDUCES RELIANCE ON UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANKS AT GAS STATIONS
WHICH LEAK INTO THE GROUND.
MOBILE ENERGY DELIVERY IS ALSO
KEY TO ACCELERATING THE ADOPTION
OF ALTERNATIVE FUELS BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT RELY ON INFRASTRUCTURAL
DEVELOPMENT. FOR EXAMPLE
RENEWABLE DIESEL PRODUCES TWO
THIRDS FEWER CARBON EMISSIONS
THAN REGULAR DIESEL BUT LESS
THAN 2% OF GAS STATIONS
CURRENTLY OFFERING. MISTERBEGAN
OFFERING RENEWABLE DIESEL JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO AND ALREADY WE
ARE DELIVERING TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLONS OF RENEWABLE
DIESEL PER MONTH. AND THE BAY
AREA ALONE HAVING SWITCHED THOSE
CLIENTS FROM REGULAR DIESEL TO
RENEWABLE DIESEL. THE SAME
PROMISE EXISTS WITH OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUELS SUCH AS TV
CHARGING AND HYDROGEN WHICH IS
WHY THIS BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HUNDRED COALITION
IN BRIEF CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT REGULATING AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY ALMOST ALL AIR
DISTRICTS HAVE AN EXEMPTION
INTENDED FOR AGRICULTURAL
PURPOSES. BUT IS BEING EXPLOITED
BY MOBILE FEELERS WHO USE PICKUP
TRUCKS TO DELIVER FUEL. THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT RECENTLY
FOUND THAT THESE OPERATORS ARE
AT LEAST FIFTY TIMES WORSE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT THEY ARE
ABLE TO OPERATE FREELY. IN SHORT
THE CURRENT REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
HAS CREATED A COUNTERINTUITIVE
SCENARIO WHERE COMPANIES ARE
INCENTIVIZED TO OPERATE IN A
LESS SAFE AND FAR MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY HARMFUL MANNER.
BECAUSE THEY CAN ESCAPE
REGULATION WHEREAS COMPANIES.
THAT WORK HARD TO ENSURE THAT
MOBILE FEELING IS THAT SAFE AND
IS RESPONSIBLE AS POSSIBLE ARE
BLOCKED FROM OPERATING. THIS
BILL WOULD RAISE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BAR FOR ALL
COMPANIES BUT IMPORTANTLY THAT
ALSO PRESERVES THE AUTHORITY OF
EACH THEIR DISTRICT TO IMPOSE
THEIR OWN THROUGHPUT SENSITIVE
RECEPTOR AND OTHER CONDITIONS AS
THEY SEE FIT. TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR DISTRICTS SPECIFIC NEEDS
ARE MET. WE THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE THE BILL AS THIS BILL
WILL IMPROVE AIR QUALITY HELP
PAVE THE WAY FOR MOBILE SERVICES
TO ACCELERATE ADOPTION OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND EXPANDED
MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR MANY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND CALIFORNIA
WHOSE INDEPENDENCE. IS LIMITED
BY SERVICE STATIONS THAT DO NOT
CURRENTLY MEET THEIR NEEDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LISA. THANK
YOU VICE CHAIR FLORA AND MEMBERS-OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LISA
HAYES I AM A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION OF
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR INDEPENDEN
LIVING ROLLING START SERVING THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY I AM A
DRIVER I'M A LONGTIME RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF BELLFLOWER AND I
COMMUTE OVER A HUNDRED MILES
DAILY TO WORK. I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
BECAUSE GAS STATIONS JUST DON'T
WORK. SINCE THE EIGHT A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
IN THIS GREAT STATE WOULD SAY
THE SAME. BUT THE SHAMEFUL WALLS
OF EXCLUSION FINALLY COME
TUMBLING DOWN WERE WORDS GEORGE
H. W. BUSH SPOKE AT THE SIGNING
OF THE ADA. THESE WORDS ARE
ETCHED AND EVERY DISABILITY%
ADVOCATES SOUL BUT AFTER THIRTY
THREE YEARS WE STILL ARE
CHALLENGED WITH ACCESS ISSUES.
WE DEAL WITH GRANDFATHER CLAUSES
SYMPATHETIC VIEWS ABLEISM OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HASN'T CHANGED
AT ALL IN OVER THIRTY YEARS SO
WHEN WE SEE A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL OF MAKING SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES. WE ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT IT WE ARE GOING
TO BACK AND WE'RE GONNA FIGHT
FOR IT. BUT IT IS TRUE. THAT
THINGS IN OUR COMMUNITY THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED IN THE
COMMUTER ADVOCATED FOR A BI ARE
ADVOCATES ARE ENJOYED BY PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES THINK OF
RAMPS CURB CUTS. TEXTING WAS
DEVELOPED BY THE DEAF COMMUNITY
AND YOU'RE ALL WELCOME. I DON'T
DOUBT MOBILE FEELING WE'LL GET
USED BY MANY MORE PEOPLE THAN US
BUT THE IMPACT ON US WILL BE
PROFOUND. I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO
TRAMPLE ON THE ENVIRONMENT SO
THAT I CAN FEEL MY CAR. OR I AM
ASKING YOU TO EMBRACE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS BETTER FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT WHILE BUILDING A
FUTURE THAT IS ACCESSIBLE TO ME.
AND TO ALL CALIFORNIANS AND IF I
COULD LEAVE YOU WITH JUST ONE
FINAL THOUGHT. I READ ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE REPORTS THAT SAID THIS
IS NOT THE TIME FOR THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT IT SENDS A BAD
MESSAGE I WANT TO CHALLENGE THAT
BECAUSE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE WILL NOT
ONLY ENSURE RESPONSIBLE MOBILE
FUELING. BUT IT WILL SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT YOU BELIEVE IN
EQUITY AND INCLUSION FOR ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT BEEN MARGINALIZED WAY
TOO LONG. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVING TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
AB TWENTY FIVE SIX THREE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAN- CONFESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CUYAMA PART OF THE
COALITION FOR CALIFORNIANS ARE
SMART FEELING AND I'M ASKING YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRYSTAL BECAUSE
I COULD CLINCH YEAH AND I'M
HERE. TO ASK FOR THE SUPPORT AND
APPROVAL FOR THIS BILL AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IS
SUPPORTED COMMITTEE ROOM. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE. OKAY THANK YOU BYE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN TO
IT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
THIRTY FIVE EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROVIDING
CLEAN AIR FOR ALL OUR RESIDENTS
WE RESPECT FOR RESPECTFULLY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE
. CAPCO IS DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CANCR CAUSING TOXIC
EMISSIONS AS WELL AS CRITERIA
AIR POLLUTANTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE OPERATIONS AND THAT IS WHY
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
THOUGHTFUL. AND MEASURED IN HOW
THEY APPROACH THE ISSUE OF ON
DEMAND FUELING OPERATIONS TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION LOCAL AIR
QUALITY NEEDS AND CONDITIONS.
THIS BILL ABANDONS THAT
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH BY REQUIRING
AIR DISTRICTS TO ESTABLISHING
ESTABLISH PERMITTING PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS AIR
DISTRICTS SPECIFICALLY FOR ON
DEMAND TANK VEHICLE OPERATIONS.
INCLUDING NEW SOURCE REVIEW
STANDARDS THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH IS ACTUALLY COUNTER TO
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERAL CLEAN AIR
ACT MANDATES REQUIRING AIR
DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT
PERMITTING AND NEW SOURCE REVIEW
RULES THAT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
NEEDS AND REQUIREMENTS AND WHILE
THE RECENTLY AMENDED VERSION
INCLUDES A PROVISION. FOR AIR
DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO COUNT
FOR LOCAL AIR QUALITY NEEDS WHEN
TAKEN TOGETHER WITH OTHER CON
CONTRADICTING REQUIREMENTS THE
BILL WILL NOT ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN. SO IN EFFECT UNDER THIS
BILL A SMALLER AIR DSTRICT LIKE
MODOC WITH A POPULATION OF
AROUND TEN THOUSAND WOULD EITHER
HAVE TO GO ABOUT THIS THE SAME
AS SAN DIEGO OR ALTERNATIVELY
SAN DIEGO WOULD HAVE TO GO ABOUT
THINGS THE SAME WAY AS MODOC OR-
IT WOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN. WHICH COULD LOWER
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
DEPENDING ON THE AIR DISTRICT IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. MEMBERS THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE. AND PROCESS
IS WORKING AS INTENDED MISTER
FIELDS IS OPERATING IN MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST AIR
DISTRICTS INCLUDING THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT SACRAMENTO BAY AREA SAN
DIEGO VENTURA AS WELL AS PLASTER
COUNTY COLLECTIVELY THESE AIR
DISTRICTS COMPLY COMPRISED CLOSE
280% OF THE STATE'S POPULATION.
YET THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR
BOOSTER FUELS ONE COMPANY.
COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE ASKING
FOR SPECIAL TREATMENT AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE BOOSTER FUELS TO
ENGAGE INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS IN
WHICH THEY WANT TO OPERATE
INSTEAD OF PURSUING POLICIES
THAT ARE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND WE RESPECTFULLY- BUT
NOT HAVE WITH ME TODAY- TIMELY
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION TO HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF THE NEED
ARISES THANK YOU. YES BY ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEING NONE
MATTER MODERATE WILL GO TO
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE. YOUR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT IS THE
ONE THAT IS ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
LINE NUMBERS FILES PLEASE
CONTACT. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE ONE L. H. PLEASE CONTACT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S ADDED
SUCH. AND I'M CALLING OTHER
PERSON WITH THE DISABILITY AT
THE BACKGROUND THE CALIFORNIANS
FIRST PART YOU LIKE CALL IT A
VERY STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
REGARD TO MY NUMBER ONE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FRANKLIN ALIAH
CO FOUNDER OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SPINAL CORD INJURY
FOUNDATION OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
WITH PARALYSIS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY ADVOCATING
FOR A YES VOTE. THANK YOU
REPORTER MY NUMBER SEVENTY FAR
PHYSICAL HAD. GET YOUR NUMBERS
KIANA SAID YOU'RE A ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION OR THANK YOU. WEDO
NOT HAVE ANY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS REYES. THANK YOU-
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOUR
WITNESS FROM BUILDING STARTS ONE
OF OUR STAR. ORGANIZATIONS BACK
IN ST BERNARD DINO WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF. THE WORK THAT REALLY
START BECAUSE- OF IN THE
COMMENTS ON THE OPPOSITION THEY
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. I DO SEE THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING THIS. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
TWO THINGS- ONE IS. HAVING A
LEGISLATION THAT IS FOR THE
BENEFIT OF. ONE COMPANY AS
OPPOSED TO AN INDUSTRY- MISTER
FUELS- THE OTHER IS. THE COMMENT
REGARDING THE DEBT THAT THE
DETRIMENT TO PUBLIC HEALTH
ALTHOUGH I DO NOTE THAT IN THE
ANALYSIS IT TALKS ABOUT TO
REQUIRING INTERFERENCE TO THE
STRICTEST EMISSION CONTROL
STANDARDS SO YEAH- THAT'S A LIE.
I'M SORRY. BUT LET ME. OR AT THE
SOUTH COAST AIR DISTRICT HAS THE
BAY AREA EXEMPTS THEM. IF THEY
WERE- A PROBLEM WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH. THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN
NEVER AND IN FACT THE DISTRICTS
THAT DON'T ALLOW THIS ALLOW
THESE ARE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
GALLON- A- PICKUP TRUCKS TO GO
AROUND IN FEEL WITH NO
ENVIRONMENTAL NO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERN AT ALL THEY'RE THE ONES
YOU'RE POLLUTING. THIS IS A NON
BAYERN MENTAL BILL THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE THINGS SAFE FOR PEOPLE
AND I'M JUST TIRED OF HEARING
WHAT YOU JUST SAID BECAUSE IF IT
WERE THE CASE AND FURTHER. WE
AWHILE IF THEY WANT TO HAVE MORE
REGULATION DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY
THEY CAN DO IT. AND IT'S NOT
JUST FOR ONE COMPANY IT'S FOR
ANYONE WHO IS IN THIS BUSINESS
SO IT IS FOR THE INDUSTRY. BUT
IN ADDITION WHAT IT DOES IS IT
CLEANS UP THE ENVIRONMENT BY
SAYING YOU EVERYBODY HAS TO HAVE
THE SAME SET OF RULES EVERYBODY
HAS TO HAVE EMISSIONS CONTROL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON- MISTER CORE GUY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- AS MANY OF YOU ALL
KNOW MY SON IS IN THE SPINA
BIFIDA COMMUNITY- JUST HAVING
THE ABILITY FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT DON'T REALIZE THAT THERE'S
A LOT. THAT GOES INTO. BEING
ABLE TO BE MOBILE BEING ABLE TO
BE ACTIVISM WE HEARD IN
TESTIMONY TODAY. AND I WANT TO
THANK. ALL OF YOU FOR MAKING IT
IN. AND TRAVELING BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S DIFFICULT. THIS IS NEEDED
THIS IS PAST DUE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS TYPE OF RESOURCE.
JUSTICE SOMETHING SIMPLE THAT WE
ALL TAKE FOR GRANTED IS AS
SIMPLE AS PUTTING FUEL IN THE
VEHICLE. IS A VERY. AND AS WE'VE
SEEN PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
CAN BE EXTREMELY PROACTIVE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN CIVIC
DISCUSSION AS SEEN TODAY IF THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO SO.
MISTER CORK I WOULD LOVE TO BE A
JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS WITH YOU.
WE'LL DISCUSS LATER- CAN
CERTAINLY MAKE YOU ACROSS ALL
TAKE WHATEVER I CAN GET THIS
NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
. ANY OTHER OF THE COMMITTEE.
CNN DOT ORG THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FORWARD- HOUSE
ECHOING COLLEAGUES COMMENTS IT
IS REMARKABLE WHEN YOU THINK OF
JUST THE BARRIERS DISASSEMBLES
GETTING FUEL CELL- I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING THIS FORWARD
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS AND
ANDERSTON AIRPORTS CONCERNS AS
WELL BUT- I THINK THIS IS NEEDED
AND I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT. YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES WE
WE'VE- GONE. OVER BACKWARDS TO
GIVE THE LOCAL DISTRICTS MORE
AND MORE CONTROL ORIGINALLY. THE
STANDARD WAS GOING TO BE SET-
AND ESSENTIALLY REGULATION DONE
BY THE AIRPORT WE HAVE GIVEN THE
LOCAL DISTRICTS. MORE AND MORE
CONTROL OF THE PROCESS THERE NOW
IN CONTROL OF THE PROCESS. IF
THEY DON'T LIKE THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT THE AIRPORT IS TALKED ABOUT
THEY CAN GO FOR A DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY. AND AGAIN. WHAT
THESE DISTRICTS ARE DOING IS
ALLOWING POLLUTING VEHICLES. TO
GO. UNREGULATED AND AT THE SAME
TIME NOT ALLOW A SYSTEM WHICH IS
. JUST AT THE TOP OF WHAT CAN BE
DONE TECHNOLOGICALLY AND IS NOT
PRESENT ME HOW ANY HEALTH
PROBLEMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST FROM YOUR TAKEN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. OH SURE
ABSOLUTELY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE- WE DO
MOST OF THEM I'M OF THE BILL.
PER FISCAL MOTION IS PASS AS A
MAN TO A- RIVAS. FLORA HI LAURA
I BOERNER HORVATH OUR BEST HI
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. REYES
REYES I SAY ARE TO SAY ARE TO
AYE STONE STONE I WOULD. I WAS
ABLE TO LEAVE THE ROLE.
MANDELSON LEAVE IT OPEN. MISS
FRIEDMAN WE'RE READY WHEN YOU
ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHICH
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO TAKE
UP FIRST. AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AT GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK AND TIME OVER THE PAST
FEW WEEKS. THE ATTENDED AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN IS TO
CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN STATE
CLIMATE EXPECTATIONS AND LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. IN A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STUDY CARP CONCLUDED
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK
TO MAKE THE GHG REDUCTIONS
EXPECTED UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE. WHICH WAS THE STATE OF ALL
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES LEGISLATION
BY STEINBERG. A TWO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TO REPORT FROM THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL SITES
THAT MOST OF METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS. NPOS
ALLOCATE MORE FUNDS TOWARD
ROADWAYS AND FOR TRANSIT. BUT
MOST ALLOCATE WERE ROADWAY
FUNDING TOWARDS MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS THE NEW FACILITIES.
WEIRDED INFLECTION POINT IN
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS MUST BE
REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN BUILT OFF MULTIPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE EIGHTY
TO EIGHTY FIVE REPORT THAT
STATES A BIG CORPORATES
CORRECTION IS WARRANTED. FOR
IMPROVING HE CHANCES OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE SUCCESS
TRANSLATED THAT MEANS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY IF
WE EXPECT TO TRULY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. ONE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE REPORT
SAID IT TO FOCUS MPO PLANS ON
FUNDING B. AND T. REDUCING
PROJECTS. AB TWO G. TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN REQUIRES EVERY USED
TO RANK AND PRIORITIZE PROJECTS
BASED ON. IT HERE AND SO THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS AND SUBMIT
THE LIST TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. AND THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION FOR REVIEW. RANK
PROJECTS WILL NOT INDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION OF THE REPORT
SAYS TO ALIGN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING TO SUSTAINABILITY
PERFORMANCE. THIS BILL PROHIBITS
A REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCY OR COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION FROM
FUNDING A PROJECT OR PROGRAM.
DETERMINED TO BE INCONSISTENT
WITH ITS MOST RECENTLY PREPARE
TO STABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGIES
OR THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS.
NPOS HERE TO THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS SHALL RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FROM STE A SURPLUS STATE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS AND FEDERAL
FUNDS. ANOTHER THIS BILL CREATES
A TASK FORCE OVERSEEN BY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
INCORRECT IN. CONSULTATION WITH
ERA B. H. TO THE IN HOUSE TO
REVIEW ALL THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF NPOS
INCLUDING DEFINING WHAT A
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY IS. THE
BILL HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
GREATER LYMAN INFORMATION
TRANSPARENCY OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS FUNDED BY LOCAL TAX
MEASURES. REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO
REPORT ON LOCAL TAX MEASURES TO
THE CTC WITH MOURNED FOR
INFORMATION ON THE FLEXIBILITY
IN THE PROJECTS OF WHETHER THEY
WILL MEET OUR STATE CLIMATE
GOALS. SOME OF THESE LEGACY
PROJECTS FUNDED BY LOCAL TAX
MEASURES WERE APPROVED BEFORE
OUR AB THIRTY TWO GOALS WERE
ESTABLISHED MOVING HAVEN'T BEEN
REVISITED IN MANY MANY YEARS. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION AS WE TWEAK AND
REFINE THE LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION. AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION SUGGEST IT'S
CONSIDERED IN A CONSIDERED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. OUR
INTENT IS NOT TO STOP SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS BUT TO
RAISE OUR STATE CLIMATE GOALS
THE SAME LEVEL OF PRIORITY WHEN
IT COMES TO CONSIDERING FUNDING.
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AT A
LOCAL LEVEL CHANGE IS NOT EASY
IT'S DIFFICULT BUT WE HAVE TO
START SOMEWHERE AND THIS BILL%
IS. ONE OF MY HIGHEST PRIORITY
BILLS MEANT TO ALIGN OUR STATE
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES WITH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON AS ROGER
DICKINSON WITH CIVIC WELL AND
BILL BOB. MACK MCGOVERN FROM THE
COALITION COALITION FROM CLEAN
AIR AND I'M SORRY IT'S BEEN A
VERY LONG DAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION OF THIS. BILL AND REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH HER FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
ROGER DICKINSON POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR CIVIC WELL FORMERLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS
DESCRIBED THE BILL WELL AND WE
THANK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP. AS
SOME OF YOU KNOW I AM ALSO A
FORMER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AMONG OTHER THINGS.
AS A SACRAMENTO SUPERVISOR I WAS
THE INSTIGATOR F WHAT BECAME
KNOWN AS THE SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS OR SAY
COG BLUEPRINT. THE BLUEPRINT
SERVED AS A TEMPLATE FOR SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY THEN
SENATOR DARRELL STEINBERG IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB
OF DESCRIBING THE BACKGROUND
INTENT OF SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
IS A SEMINAL STEPS. TO
INTEGRATING LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION. AND REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS. UNFORTUNATELY DUE TOTHE ABSENCE OF A PRACTICAL MEANS
OF ENSURING THAT THE ACTIONS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COINCIDE WITH
THE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGIES ADOPTED BY NPOS. THE
INTENT OF S. B. THREE SEVENTY
FIVE TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
IT'S FALLING SHORT. AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY SEVEN ADDRESSES THIS
FOUNDATIONAL DEFICIENCY BY
REQUIRING AMONG OTHER THINGS.
ONE AM PO'S TO PRIORITIZE FUND
AND IMPLEMENT PROJECTS IN THERE
ARE T. P.'S BY- GHG EMISSION
REDUCTION BENEFITS TO A. R. B.
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE C. T.
C. TO REVIEW AND DETERMINE
WHETHER PROJECTS IN RTP HE'S-
ALIGNED WITH STATE CLIMATE
GOALS. THREE FUNDING THOSE
PROJECTS THAT ARE CONSISTENT.
WITH THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
AND NOT FUNDING THOSE PROJECTS
WHICH ARE INCONSISTENT FOR.
PROJECTS INCLUDED LOCAL TAX
MEASURES TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS IN
ORDER TO BE FUNDED AND FIVE
ADDITIONAL SURPLUS STATE AND
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDS GO
TO M. PO'S THAT APPROVED
PROJECTS. THAT IT HERE TO THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS OUR LARGEST SOURCE OF
GHG EMISSIONS IN ORDER TO MEET
THE PROMISE OF SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE AND THE CRITICAL CHALLENGE
OF REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT OUR PRECIOUS TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING IS LIMITED TO THOSE
PROJECTS TO FULFILL THAT PROMISE
AND OVERCOME THAT CHALLENGE. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN WILL DO
SO I RESPECTFULLY URGE- I VOTE
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMANMEMBERS
BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT A THREE LEGGED STOOL
CLEANING UP OUR ENGINES CLEANING
UP OUR FUELS WE MADE SOME
PROGRESS ON THOSE FRONTS NEED TO
DO MORE. BUT THE THIRD AREA WE
REALLY HAVEN'T MADE PROGRESS AND
THAT'S IN REDUCING THE MILES
TRAVELED BY OUR VEHICLES AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO BADLY
NEEDED AND ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
OBSTACLES HAS BEENTHAT OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING HAS OFTEN
BEEN DRIVING EMISSIONS UP.
RATHER THAN DOWN AND THAT'S WHY
WE NEED THIS BILL TO ALIGN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WITH THE
NEED TO REDUCE THE EMISSIONS
THAT ARE MAKING PEOPLE SICK AND
KILLING PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND ALSO CHANGING THE
PLANET'S CLIMATE. AT THE GLOBAL
LEVEL AND LET'S REMEMBER THAT IF
WE CONTINUE TO VIOLATE NATIONAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS WE NOT
ONLY CONTINUE TO MAKE OUR PEOPLE
SICK WE POTENTIALLY JEOPARDIZED
FUTURE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN. I'VE GOT MY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MELISSA
ROMERO CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IT WILL ALSO SUPPORT. IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE COME UP.
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THIS
BILL I REPRESENT- TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA MY NAME IS MARC WATTS
AND TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA IS
A COALITION OF INDUSTRY AND
ALLIED LABOR. AND AS THE CHAIR-
INDICATED EARLIER ON IN HER
CONVERSATION THAT SHE'S BEEN
WORKING WITH US AND THEY TRULY
HAVE THE SHE AND HER STAFF HAVE
HELD SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH US AS
WE WENT THROUGH THE BILL LINE BY
LINE AND- THREE EACH AMENDMENT.
ESSENTIALLY WE OPPOSE IT READ AT
THIS POINT TIME BECAUSE WE THINK
IT'S OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE-
BECAUSE WHILE THE CITY CONTINUES
TO HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
DEVELOPING GUIDELINES FOR EACH
OF THE SES'S THE BILL NOW BRINGS
IN. A RB AND OPR TOOK TO IT
AFTER THE FACT REVIEW OF WHAT
THE PRODUCT WAS AND SO IT'S HARD
TO PUT TOGETHER A PROGRAM THAT
ANTICIPATES. OF THE SECONDARY
VIEW- THE R. T. P. A. AND
IMPERIAL ROLE HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
BALANCE MOBILITY NEEDS. WITH
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING. AND
OVERALL EACH SCS IS TO HAVE A
NET NEGATIVE GHG REDUCTION-
DOESN'T SAY UNTIL NOW SO YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE EVERY
PROJECT- MEET PM TEAR G. ISSUE.
SO THAT A MAJOR CHANGE COULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES ESPECIALLY WITH THE SELF
HELP COUNTY. EXPENDITURE PLANS
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AS THE CHAIR OF
THE TUNE REPORT WORK ON LANGUAGE
ON THAT- FINALLY- AS I WAS JUST
DISCUSSING THE SUFFOLK COUNTY.
THE LATEST MEMBERS TO NOT SINK
THE PRIOR A REQUIREMENT THERE
ARE TWO PA'S. MAY NOT FUND.
PROJECTS JUST TO BE OUT OF SYNC
WITH THE YES YES. IT DOES THEN
SEVEN CONTINUES THAT MANDATE
WHETHER OR NOT WE'VE GOT THE NEW
SET OF- GUIDELINES AND RULES SO
WITH THAT. HOME OF BRING MY
PRESENTATION TO CLOSE AND THANK
THE- CHAIR FRIEDMAN UNDERSTAFFED
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- DEVON
COMPLICATE CALIFORNIA CITIES I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION BUT
CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED- IF THE
BILL WERE TO. MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO
FOR OUR AND HAVE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION COMMITTEE ROOM. C. N.
NINE MEMORY OF THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN. YOUR
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT IS
ONE BAND ZERO. I ONLY HAVE ONE
ON ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THAT THIS WILL BEAR IT
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE. THANK YOU YOUR VOTE SO
I NUMBER NINETY ONE. GOOD
EVENING NORTHERN AFRICAN THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA APPLESEED
MANIFESTATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THREE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU ROBOTO I NUMBER ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE THIS IS BUT THE FISH FROM
STREETS FOR ALL L. A. COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT THE LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT. BASEBALL
HAT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS REX W. HI MY BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
THE STATION ALSO POSED THANK YOU. RIGHT NUMBER FORTY NINE.
CRISPLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER ONE OH SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE NO ONE ELSE
SEVEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
PAPER HI KATHY SEE FIRSTHAND
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A BOTTOM LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN THE HEAD. STEIN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
OPPOSED THANK YOU. NUMBER FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK HEARING NO RESPONSE WE
WILL CLOSE OUT WITH NO
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEVEN SO. I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
GET PEOPLE AWAY FROM TRAVELING
ON ON ROADS BUT- IN AREAS WHERE
YOU HAVE ROADS ALREADY KNEW HAD
THEM FOR A LONG TIME THAT'S
GREAT FOR AREAS THAT ARE BEING
PRESSURED TO BUILD MORE HOUSES
SO THAT WE CAN- SUPPORT- THE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE HOUSES
RIGHT NOW AND TRY TO REGAIN OUR
BALANCE IN HOUSING. WE DON'T
HAVE ROADS OUT THERE WE DON'T
HAVE ROADS IN AND RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES- IT N.
WE ARE DESPERATE TO COMPLETE
SOME OF THE ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE
SO PEOPLE CAN GET AROUND OUT
THERE- DURING THE SUMMER TIMES
IT IS HOT. THERE IS NO THERE'S
NO BIKING THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO GET PEOPLE TO JOBS
THAT DON'T EXIST YET- BECAUSE-
IN ORDER FOR JOBS DO EXIST WE
HAVE TO HAVE TO COMPANIES COME
IN AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE ROADS
TO GET TO THEIR COMPANIES. WE
CAN GET PEOPLE FROM COMMUTING
SIXTY MILES IF WE CAN FOCUS ON
THAT. BUT DID TO DRAW TAKE MONEY
AWAY FROM ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE-
DOESN'T SUIT A LOT OF PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE THE-
POTENTIAL TO GROW MORE. AND
ACCEPT THE HOUSING IN THE
BUILDING THAT NEEDS TO OCCUR TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR HOUSING NEEDS.
AND AND THIS I DON'T SEE THIS
HELPING US. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M GONNA HAVE TO OPPOSE BILL
TODAY THINK. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. SAM
NUNN THREE ONE JULY TO CLOSE
SURE- CERTAINLY I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THAT ERE RAISED- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION- TO CLARIFY THE BILL
WE'VE COME QUITE A LONG WAY THE
BILL CERTAINLY IS NOT GOING TO
PROHIBIT THE BUILDING OF ROADS
IN CALIFORNIA BUT IT DOES SEEK
TO. HELP TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS
THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS SINCE
ADMITTED THAT ARE TRANSIT
PROJECTS PRIMARILY TO MOVE SO
THAT WE DO. ADEQUATELY FUND
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
DONE IF YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT GOES INTO A TRANCE
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN COMPARED TO
SOME OF THE OTHER STATES YOU'LL
SEE THAT WERE REALLY WOEFULLY
BEHIND IN FUNDING OF PROJECTS
THAT PROVIDE. SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS AS WELL
AS EQUITY IN WAYS FOR PEOPLE TO
GET AROUND IF THEY CAN'T AFFORD
OR CHOOSE TO NOT HAVE A CAR AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO
DO AND I WOULD APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOTIONS DO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. RIVAS LARA NO. STORE
NO BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NO MURATSUCHI
READ SU CHI I REYES REYES I
SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO STONE.
STONE I WOULD WOOD I. IT HAS.
SEVEN YES BILLS AS A VOTE IN
ITSELF SO MOVING ON TO AB TWENTY
SIX TEN. THIS BILL I THINK IS AN
EASY BILL FOR FOLKS ON I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK IN TIME AB
TWENTY SIX TEN CREATES A GRANT
PROGRAM UNDER THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO SUPPORT
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE IT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS.
THESE PROJECTS MITIGATE FIRE
RISK BY REDUCING WILDFIRE FUEL
LOADS IN A MANNER THAT MAINTAINS
BIODIVERSITY AND PRESERVES
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SPECIES
AT SOME CASES PREVENTS WILDFIRE
RISK GETTING WORSE BY SPREADING
THE INVASIVE NON NATIVE PLANTS.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM WILL ALSO
SUPPORT LOCAL AGENCIES RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
CONSERVANCIES NONPROFITS AND
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES IN
PROVIDING WORKFORCE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS AND
HELP US REDUCE WERE- HELP US
REACH BOTH OUR FUEL REDUCTION
GOALS IN OUR BIO DIVERSITY GOALS
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON IS DOUG JOHNSON.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INVASIVE PLANT
COUNCIL AND CODY CIFUENTES
WINTER SENIOR RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT SPECIALIST WITH THE
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LEARN MORE ASPECT
OF GO REBEKAH LEAGUE- TESTIFIED
OVER THE PHONE PLEASE. THANK
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DOUG
JOHNSON- IN MY LIFE. YOU ARE
BECAUSE YOU. RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS- JOHNSON
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA INVASIVE
PLANT COUNCIL AND WE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS WORK TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND
ECONOMY FROM INVASIVE PLANT.
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE LAND MANAGERS AS
WELL AS ECOLOGICAL RESEARCHERS
PLANNERS COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS
AND CONCERNED BUT OFTEN AND WE
ARE A CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
SIX TEN. THE BILL SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FOR FUEL
REDUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND OF
COURSE WE ALL KNOW PARDON IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE BEEN SUBJECT
EVER INTENSIFYING WILDFIRES
ACROSS THE STATE IN RESPONSE THE
STATE OF THE FABLESS CONDITIONS
FUEL REDUCTION GOALS TO REDUCE
VEGETATION OVERGROWTH. ELEMENT
WILDFIRE RISK- HOWEVER SO MUCH
WORK NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO FAST TO
REACH THE FUEL REDUCTION GOALS
THAT THE FOURTH HEALTH OF
MANAGEMENT AGENCY AREN'T ALWAYS
ABLE TO FULLY PRIORITIZE LONG
TERM ECOLOGICAL IMPACT. LARGE
SCALE THAT STATION MANAGEMENT
SOME OF THE COMMONLY USED
TECHNIQUES CAN SPREAD INVASIVE
PLANTS CAN DAMAGE NATIVE
VEGETATION WHICH CAN ULTIMATELY
LEAD TO DENTAL VEGETATION AND
HEIGHTENED FIRE RISK AND ALSO
INCREASE STRAP ON OUR WILDLIFE
AND REDUCE OUR CLIMATE
RESILIENT. ECOLOGICALLY
SENSITIVE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM CREATED BY AB TWENTY SIX
AND WILL PROVIDE FUNDING TO LAND
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATIONS
IMPLEMENT INNOVATIVE PROJECTS
ACROSS THE STATE THE PROJECT
WILL REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK OER
THE LONG TERM IN AN ECOLOGICALLY
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. AND HELP
FIELD TESTING OF ASIANS THAT CAN
EVENTUALLY BE MAINSTREAMED INTO
THE MAJOR UEL CORE CALLING ON
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS FOR
INCREASING WILDFIRE SAFETY
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY AND
BUILDING CLIMATE RESILIENT FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON BY CHAIR REMEMBER MY
NAME IS CODY POINT TO POINT AND
I A SENIOR RESEARCH MANAGEMENT.
AT THE MID OF CAN OPEN PLACES.
AND THE PUBLIC NOW FROM MILLION
DOT WHILE EMPIRE BILLING PROGRAM. I WOULD WITH THE HOT SPOT
AREAS THAT ARE BOTH. WITH WHITE
CANVAS HOGAN DISCO. MAKE UP
ABOUT TWO POINT 2% OF THE- EARTH
PLAN SURFACE. THAT CONTAINS 40%
OF ALL PLAY. 35% THE LAND BURGER
BUT. CALIFORNIA'S DEATH ONE OF
THE- OVER THIRTY. BIOLOGICAL
HOTSPOT THE WORLD. COMPATIBLE
WITH FIFTY DOLLARS ACRES OF
ACQUIRED PROTECTED- OPEN SPACE
ON THE DIFFERENCE OPINION.
REPAIRS NO LONGER REGIONAL SPACE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROUD
BECAUSE THE AB TWENTY TWO TEN.
IT CONNECT TO PER OPEN SPACES
THE HEART OF MISSION. THIS
INCLUDES NOT ONLY. SOUND THAT'S
NOT THE PROTECT WHICH GO TO
PHONE BY. ALTHOUGH AND DEVELOP
PUBLIC AD PARTNER TO CRY.
ACTION ONE MUST BOTTLENECKED BE
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT TO OUR
ACTIVE IN MY INCLUDING OUR PARTY
. IF EACH CUT WEEK A LOT OF
PEOPLE VEGETATION. WHICH SWEPT
ON. IMPROVING OVER BECAUSE
HEALTH LAND. HI LEVINE BROTHER
THE BASIS. WELL THE OF. CHRIS NO
WHILE PART OF YOU WILL BE
TALKING THAT COULD NOT HAPPEN
CHEMICAL. EDUCATION WILL FOR
SHORT OF TIME. THEY CAN OPENLY
BECAUSE INVASIVE THAT BACK. MORE
RAP AND WILL BUCKLEY ALSO
INCREASING LOADS FOR ME IT MORE
TO. FOR TO SPEAK TO. MISTER
UNDERMINES THE STATE THE SALAS
CLOCKED AND BIOGRAPHER GOAL BY
INDISCRIMINATELY THE PLANT LIKE
WITH PEOPLE OF THE- HEALTH WHILE
I HAVE. FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
NATIVE PLANTS TO BE. HOW BECAUSE
BECAUSE DISTRICT META PORTABLE
EIGHTY SIX TEN AND APPROVE LONG
TERM FIRE WE GOT WHILE BUT-
NATIVE DIED BY THE BUSH IN OR-
CLICK ON FLOOD WILDFIRE ACROSS
THE STATE IMPAIR. THAT WE
SUPPORT FEWER WE PART. BEYOND
THE CARRIED OUT BY THE- THIS
PRESS WITH THE SMALLER ENTITIES
PERHAPS TO KEEP UP WITH THE
PROJECT ECOLOGICAL. THE
COMPLEMENT OF WITH A WORK IS
ALREADY UNDERWAY AT THE STATE
LEVEL. FOR THE REASONS REFER ASK
I ON A TWENTY SIX TEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME YOU CONSIDER.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OF IN THE
ROOM. I A MILE AND A HALF
INTEREST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
REYES AND FOOTHILLS CA. IS THE
REGIONAL PARKS ON THE CALIFORNIA
GRASS ASSOC ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
THANK YOU ELSE'S OF MINIMUM C.
N. NINE A ONE OF OPPOSITION IN
THE CAN ROOM. BEAUTIFUL BETTER.
WOULD LIKE TO GO THE PHONE LINE
FOR SOME. ENOUGH TWO AB TWENTY
SIX WE HAVE FOUR. BUT CRIED I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE NOPE JUST
TWENTY SIX TEN. SORRY YOUR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IT IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IT'S
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. ONE NINE
ZERO. AND WE HAD NO WARNING Q.
WHICH CARE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CNN SO A CLOSE ROOM
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION THAT
I'M AWARE OF AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE AND I BELIEVE. THANK
YOU. EXACTLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS. FLOOR
FLOOR AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I. REYES
REYES I SEYARTO HIGH SEYARTO AYE
STONE. STONE I WOULD. WHAT HI
TEMPLE THE BILL HAS DEVOTED UP
MOVING ONTO THANK YOU FINAL AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
STAFF OF FOR THEIR FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL I'M GOING TO ACCEPT
THE SUGGESTS A COMMITTEE MEMBER
ON PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS
THE CLARIFIES THE DEFINITION OF
CLEAN DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES USED IN THE BILL I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH CREATES A NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. TO SUPPORT
INNOVATIVE NEW APPROACHES TO
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE
ADOPTION BASED ON THEIR
FUNCTIONAL ATTRIBUTES IN A
TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL MANNER
WE ALL KNOW THAT- GOING TO A
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY IS A GOAL
OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL
SEEKS TO REMEDY THAT A SPIRIT
AVAILABILITY OF INCENTIVE
SUPPORT BY CREATING A STATEWIDE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THE CUSTOMER
SOME PROVIDERS CAN ACCESS
REGARDLESS OF CUSTOMER LOCATION
OR ELECTRICITY PROVIDER TYPE
CURRENTLY SOME CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA- LIMITED TO STATE
MANDATED INSTEAD OF PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE ONLY THROUGH THE I'LL
USE. SOME CUSTOMRS ARE ABLE TO
CHOOSE A DEMAND SIDE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM PROVIDED BY THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATOR IF
AVAILABLE WELL SOME COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS ARE
ABLE TO RELY ON DEMAND
MANAGEMENT SERVICES BY DIRECT
ACCESS PROVIDER HOWEVER FOR
CUSTOMER SERVICE BY PO USE LIKE
MOST OF THE CONSTITUENTS IN MY
DISTRICT THE OPTIONS ARE VERY
LIMITED FOR ON SITE ELECTRICAL
ELECTRICITY DEMAND MANAGEMENT.
WE'D LIKE TO CHANGE THAT AND
OPEN THAT UP TO DIFFERENT USERS
FOR ALL OF THE BENEFITS THAT THE
OTHER- USERS ARE ABLE TO ENJOY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE
MICHAEL COLEMAN WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
REBEKAH LEAVE WITH THE ENERGY.
BOTH BY PHONE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MICHAEL OF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINE. YES HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME I
MICHAEL HOLDEN AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE FUND NINE HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIX SIX SEVEN. THE CREATION OF
THIS CONTENT A PROGRAM WILL HELP
UNLOCK DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES FOR CUSTOMERS. THE
TECHNOLOGY TO INCLUDE- DEMAND
MANAGEMENT MALL KILLED A NEW
LOOK GENERATION ENERGY STORAGE
AND SMART CHARGING OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. INTENDED TO AUTHORIZE
IN THIS BILL WILL HELP
ACCELERATE THE PEOPLE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS AND THE HELP INSURE
RELIABILITY RESILIENCY IN EQUITY
. IF YOU'RE WELL AWARE AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA P. THE
HAVE RECENTLY EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT OVER RELYING ON CUSTOMER
RATE THE FUND THE PROGRAM. AB
TWO SIX SIX SEVEN DOES NOT
UTILIZE ANY REPAIR FUNDS WILL
NOT HAVE ANY IMPACT ON THE
CUSTOMER'S ENERGY BILL. EDF WANT
THE SPOTLIGHT- THAT THIS BILL
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOUR EMISSION VEHICLES
ESPECIALLY MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES BECAUSE THEY ARE AN
EMERGING DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCE. THINK OF THEM AS-
BATTERIES ON WHEELS. AND WITH
THE STATE STREET AND ADOPTION OF
THE ADVANCED CLEAN TRUCK RULE ON
THE PENDING CONSIDERATION OF THE
AIRPLANE FLEET RULE. THIS IS. AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STATE TED
DECARBONISE ANOTHER MAJOR
PORTION OF THE ECONOMY. ANYTHING
FUNDS FROM THIS PROGRAM TO HELP
UNLOCK BY CHARGING AT THE THEIR
EMISSION VEHICLES COULD BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL BECAUSE WILL
HELP REDUCE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
AND GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS I ENCOURAGE
HER AYE THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND REBEKAH
LEE. NUMBER REBECCA LEE ON
BEHALF OF AN RG AT A DISTRIBUTOR
ENERGY PROVIDER AS WELL AS THE
DIRAC. WITH THE BITER AND
CALIFORNIA WEEK THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR THE MEASURE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW WEEK
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO BETTER
CUSTOMIZE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
SOLUTIONS TO UNWIND BALLADEERS
TO THE CUSTOMER WHAT THEY NEED
TO QUIT. FOR EXAMPLE BY HELPING
OUR CUSTOMERS COMBINED ONE OR
MORE. OF IT SHOULD BE TO ENERGY
WE CAN AGGREGATE THAT DEMAND
REDUCTION ACROSS MULTIPLE
CUSTOMERS. TO PROVIDE A CRITICAL
RESOURCE TO THE GRID THEREBY
REDUCING THE NEED TO RELY ON
ADDITIONAL FOB SO GENERATIONS
THAT BATCH. UNDERSTANDABLY
CUSTOMERS IN DIFFERENT REGIONS
OF THE STATE. WITH DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC NEEDS HAVE DIFFERENT
ENERGY DEMAND PROFILES BY
PROVIDING CUSTOMER CHOICE IN
CLEAN ENERGY SOLUTIONS WILL HELP
INCREASE EQUITY IN OUR CLEAN
ENERGY EFFORTS BY ENABLING EACH
CUSTOMER TO MAKE IT SUCH A GOOD
ENERGY. VISION BASED ON THEIR
NEEDS AND CIRCUMSTANCES WE'VE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GEICO.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IS A AND
COMMITTEE ROOM. MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESIDENTS WORK MUCH OF WHAT THE
CLINTON CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ALLWOOD TOOK WITH
CAPITAL ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE SYSTEM- CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY INCLUDES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT F
COMMITTEE REAL. SEEM NONE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN SEEN NONE. BUT A
MODERATOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION THE PHONE LINES. YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT
IS. ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
LINE NINE B. BOB THEY JUST SUCK
YOU INSTALLED MY NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON TIFFANY
FAN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
E. SUFFICIENCY AND MAN
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER NINETY NINE PLEASE BUT
HAS. GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA
HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF CAPSTONE
GREEN ENERGY AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL
HAD. HELLO ALLEY BE FREER WITH
THE MICROGRID RESOURCES
COALITION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU KNOW. THANK
YOU WHEN WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE
IN YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SCENE NINE THIS READ
WAS LIKE CLOSE- THIS BILL PASSED
THE ENERGY- COMMITTEE AND I
WOULD- ASK THAT YOU ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON IT BY
PASSING THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM SECULAR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS
. LARA. NOBODY BOERNER HORVATH
IRAQ BOERNER HORVATH I FRIEDMAN. RIGHT FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE MATHIS THOUGH MATHIS
NUMBER TWO G. MURATSUCHI I.
REYES. SEYARTO NUMBER. STONE
STONE WOULD WOOD I. THE BILL HAS
SIX WAS LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS OUT ON. WE'LL GET THIS
MEMBER TEAM WHICH BILL WOULD YOU
LIKE 2% FOR SIR. AB. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY SIX FIVE AB TWENTY SIX
ANSWER YOUR- BILL. THANK YOU- AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX EXPAND OR
JUST ENSURE THAT WE CLARIFY THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT WHICH
WAS PASSED INTO LAW IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO TO LIMIT THE ABILITY
OF LOCAL AGENCIES TO DENY
QUALIFYING. HOUSING PROJECTS
FROM BEING BUILT IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. WHAT THIS DOES IS
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
CLARIFIES. AROUND THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY OU THAT IF IT
LOCAL JURISDICTION IS GOING TO
ASK FOR FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW THEY HAVE TO. BE ABLE TO
THEY CAN ONLY ASK WHAT SEE WHAT
ACTUALLY. REQUIRES OR HAS THE
ATTRIBUTES UNDER SEQUEL ALSO IF
A PROJECT IS. DECLARED EXEMPT
UNDER SEEK WITH A DEAF PRACTICAL
DREAMS ACT- THERE IS NO
EXPANSION OF SEQUEL- THERE IS NO
TOUCHING OF SYKORA. IN THE
LEGISLATION THIS BILL COMES
ABOUT BECAUSE WE HAD TWO
INSTANCES IN MY DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE WE HAD
UNFORTUNATELY- PROJECTS THAT HAD
GONE THROUGH. THE ENTIRE SUPER
PROCESS BUT OF COURSE THEY WERE
DENIED WITHOUT ANY FURTHER
CLARIFICATION OR WITHOUT ANY
PARTICULAR REMEDY I HAVE A
MICHAEL LANE HERE FROM SPUR AND
CORNELIUS- BURKE FROM CBI. THE
TEAM IS FOR WITH US MISTER
MISTER MEMBERS MY- FOR PUBLIC
THINK IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
DOES NOT TOUCH THE GUN ANYWAY
NOR DOES IT ALTER ANY EXISTING
RIGHTS OR RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
EXIST IN CURRENT LAW WITH REGARD
TO THAT STATUTE. THIS BILL IN NO
WAY ELIMINATES OR LIMITS LAWFUL
AND LEGITIMATE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW NOR DOES IT CHANGE THE
QUICK TIME LINES OR TRUNCATE THE
PROCESS. FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS WERE RECENTLY
ADMITTED IN THE BILL TO
EXPLICITLY CONVEYED ITS INTENT
TO CLARIFY EXISTING LAW AND
CODIFY EIGHT CITIES
INTERPRETATION OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. IT'S
INTERACTION WITH SEQUEL. THE
BILL DOES NOT EXPAND THE
DEFINITION DISAPPROVAL UNDER THE
HIPAA WHICH BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
IS FOUND AND COURTS HAVE
RECOGNIZED ALREADY BROADLY
INCLUDES ANY REQUIRED LAND USE
APPROVALS OR ENTITLEMENTS
NECESSARY FOR THE ISSUANCE OF
BUILDING A BUILDING PERMIT. WELL
THE HA DOES NOT EXEMPT PROJECTS
FROM SEEK WHAT IT ALSO DOES NOT
AUTHORIZE CITIES TO DEVISE A
QUICKLY EARNS TO WHICH A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS LEGALLY ENTITLED.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX REALLY
REQUIRES A SEQUENCE OPTION
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS. THAT A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO BASED ON THE RECORD
BEFORE THE AGENCY BE GRANTED.
MORE THAN A I. R. OR NECK DECK
WITH A LEGALLY SUFFICIENT BASIS
IN THE RECORD. BE ADOPTED. THIS
IN NO WAY PRECLUDES ADDITIONAL
STUDY IF THE NEED IS IDENTIFIED.
THE FACT IS AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX ONLY SIX TO ENFORCE THE LAWS
AROUND ENVIRONMENT REVIEW. THAT
ARE ALREADY IN STATUTE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THE VERY MUCH CHRIS. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE THE
HOMEBUILDING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY SIX BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. IN FACT WE
HAVE DOESN'T IT THIS BILL IS A
HOUSING CREATOR. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BECAUSE IT REDUCES
THE BARRIERS. TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND EFFORT TO
ALLEVIATE OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
SIMPLY CLOSE A LOOPHOLE AND THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
BRIEFLY CREATED BY SOME TO ADD
ADDITIONAL STEPS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY LENGTHY AND COMPLICATED.
HOUSING APPROVAL PROCESS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE FOR. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
CREATOR. AND IT WILL HELP IN OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADRIN MUHAMMAD WITH THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY FOR
CALIFORNIA SAND HILL PROPERTY
COMPANY AND CIVIC WHILE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF COMMITTEE ROOMS.
C. NONE THE OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY SIX IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM.
GOOD EVENING I CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TANYA
GLOUCESTER IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
STATE BUILDING A CONTRACT
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO SIX FIVE
SIX THE BILL WILL REDEFINE- LAND
USE LAWS IN CALIFORNIA BY
CREATING A NEW DEFINITION OF
PROJECT DISAPPROVAL THAT
INCLUDES. SOME POINT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS IT PROHIBITS
AGENCY DECISION MAKERS FROM
COMPLYING WITH THEIR STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS TO CONDUCT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
REVIEW WHEN THEY REASONABLY
BELIEVE BASED ON THE EVIDENCE IN
THE RECORD THAT A PROJECT IS NOT
EXEMPT FROM SEA QUEST OR HAS NOT
MET THE LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
MITIGATE OUR PROJECTS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. ALLOWING
A DISCUSSION ABOUT ELIGIBILITY
OF AN EXEMPTION OR THAT FURTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IS REQUIRED
TO BE A BASIS FOR LITIGATION IN
THE MIDDLE OF A SECRET PROCESS
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE DETERMINING
WHETHER A PROJECT IS EXEMPT IS A
DISCRETIONARY DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. FOR EXAMPLE ALL
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS OF
CLASSES ONE THREE THIRTY THREE
ARE SUBJECT TO EXTENT EXCEPTIONS
IN THE SEQUEL GUIDELINES EVEN OF
A PROJECT IS SPATIALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR SICK BUT- EXEMPTION NO
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTION CAN BE
USED IF FOR EXAMPLE THE PROJECT
IS ON A THIRTIES THE LAST OR
IT'S IN A NIGHT. OF PARTICULAR
LOCATION OR THEIR CUMULATIVE
IMPACTS OR UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES
THIS IS THE DELIBERATION THAT
GOES ON BEFORE A LOCAL AGENCY
WHETHER AN EXCEPTION TO AN
EXEMPTION APPLIES AS A FACT
BASED DECISION- THAT MUST BE
MADE BASED ON EVIDENCE IN THE
RECORD SIMILARLY A DECISION
ABOUT WHETHER WE'RE PROJECT
REQUIRES FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW IS PART OF THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. I'M FOR EXAMPLE
A PRIOR SUPER REVIEW COULD BE
DONE THEN WE HAVE A RESIDENTIAL
PROJECT COME INTO THE AREA
PERHAPS THE FOOTPRINT CHANGES
ARE THE PROJECT GETS BETTER
BAKER THE AGENCY HAS THE DUTY
UNDER SEA QUEST. TO GO AND DO
FURTHER ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW TO
REQUIREMENTS. MEASURES BEFORE IT
APPROVES THAT PROJECT THIS BILL
WOULD CUT THAT PROCESS SHORT AND
WOULD HAVE IMPROPERLY PLACES THE
DECISION MAKING POCESS IN THE
HANDS OF THE COURT'S. DENIAL OF
SECRET CLEARANCE IS PRECISELY
NOT ENCOMPASSED WITHIN THE HHS
DEFINITION OF DISAPPROVAL IN
FACT THE HA A SAYS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE. NOTHING SHALL. AFFECT
COMPLIANCE WITH SEPA. THERE IS
NO- INCONSISTENCY SEQUEL
REQUIRES FINDINGS BE MADE UNDER
THAT STATUTE AND THE HA A
REQUIRES FINDINGS TO ME MADE.
UNDER THAT STATUTE THIS BILL
WOULD BE INCONSISTENT WITH BOTH
OF THE STATUTES. FINALLY AB TWO
SIX FIVE SIX IS A VIOLATES THE
BASIC ADMINISTRATIVE EXHAUSTION
PRINCIPLES ARE ALLOWING THE
LAWSUIT TO CHALLENGE THE NILE OF
A PROJECT BY AN AGENCY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS WITHOUT
FIRST REQUIRING- CHALLENGER WHO
DEVELOPER. TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF THE PROCESS OF
EXHAUSTING ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDIES EVEN THOUGH THE SECRET
PROCESS REQUIRES CITIZEN GROUPS
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
APPEALING AN AGENCY DECISION A
PLANNING COMMISSION DECISION TO
THE NEXT APPELLATE DECISION
MAKING BODY- IT EXHAUSTED. IT
VIOLATES THE EXHAUSTION
REQUIREMENTS UNDER LOCAL
PROCEDURES UNDER MUNICIPAL CODE
OR COUNTY'S ORDINANCE AND ALSO
VIOLATES THE EXHAUSTION
PRINCIPLES IN SEA QUEST. THIS
SEQUEL ALLOWS APPEALS OF AN E.
I. ARE MITIGATED NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT BACK. TO THE ELECTED
DECISION MAKING BODY. I'M IT IS
ALSO IN CA WITH THE CODE OF
CIVIL PROCEDURE BOTH TEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND TEN NINETY FOUR POINT
FIVE WHICH ARE THE METHODS FOR
BRINGING LAND USE APPROVALS-
CHALLENGES UNDER SECRET UNDER
STATE LAW. WITH RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. C. NINE MADAME MODERATOR
THE PHONE RIGHT PHONE LINE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO AB.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
FOR IN ORDER OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE. MANZANERO AGAIN THAT
IS ONE SEVEN ZERO FOR ANY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN DO YOU HAVE A SON YOU. WE
WILL MOE ON TO LINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY YES
IT ALL THESE HIGH HI THERE
JENNIFER TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE OH SIX
ZERO LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARK THE
BILL THE HEATING PROCESS VOTERS
LOCAL SIXTEEN I STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THE NEED FOR ROLE
PLAYING FOOTBALL WITH THE LABOR
DISTRICT COUNCIL BEEN TALKING TO
CALIFORNIA AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW ABOUT THE LINE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
JORDAN CANNOT COVER THE WHOLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS TIMOTHY JEFFRIES THE NEW WITH
I'M STANDING IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
SIX AT THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
BUT IT'S JUST BECOME TRANSIT
POINTED OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MIND SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PINE SEVENTY SEVEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO YOU HAVE A
SON YOU. NOW WITH THAT- WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS RACE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. BUT OF ALL THE
BILLS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
TODAY THIS IS THE ONE THAT
CAUSED ME THE MOST
CONSTERNATION- HI. RIGHT THE
AUTHOR HOWEVER MAKES THE
DIFFERENCE HERE- I THINK THAT
HAVING THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION I KNOW IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING ON.
BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT
TO THE WORK THAT WE DO A SPECIAL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ABOUT
HOUSING- THE- FOR TODAY I WILL
GIVE A COURTESY AYE VOTE. AND
I'D I KNOW THAT THE ANALYSIS
THAT WAS PREPARED GIVEN NUMBER
OF ITEMS THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I KNOW THAT THOSE
WILL BE ADDRESSED AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THAT BUT- WITH
THAT I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT. YES
MISTER KING I YOU KNOW I FEEL
LIKE AND I LISTEN AS I LISTEN TO
THE OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT HERE
IT AND IT IT DOES FEEL LIKE
THERE IS THERE IS A WAY TO GET
THIS DONE GET WHAT YOU NEED TO
GET DONE AND- I'M SORRY THAT
THAT THAT HASN'T HAPPENED TO
THIS POINT BUT I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU A COURTESY AYE VOTE TO MOVE
THIS ALONG TO GIVE YOU THAT
OPPORTUNITY. GREAT THANK YOU. IN
AN OBSOLETE WILL WILL CONTINUE
AFTER DISCUSSIONS- WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
ISSUES. AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THE
VALASSIS AND WE ABSOLUTELY I
WILL CONTINUE TO. CONTINUE TO
WORK ON HOPES OF REACHING RIVER
FOR WHICH A FLOOR. FIFTEEN CAN I
JUST TELL HARPER ONE COMMENT I
THINK WE ACTUALLY- CLOSER THAN
IT APPEARED FROM OUR COMMENTS I
THINK BECAUSE WE WANT TO
EXHAUST. THE LOCAL REMEDIES TO
AND GO THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL UNDER
SEQUEL- BEFORE THAT THIS WOULD
EVEN- TAKE PLACE THAT THE ACTION
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE HA. AND
FOR EXAMPLE IF IT'S ON A CORTES
OF THIS THAT'S WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT. YOU CAN'T HAVE AN
EXEMPTION WAS GONNA LITIGATE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE SO I THINK
THERE IS. THE POTENTIAL FOR MANY
OF THE MINES HERE. MISTER SEG.
I'M SORRY. THAT COMMENT- THE
FACT THAT THERE WOULD BE A COURT
DECISION IN THE MIDDLE OF SICK
BOY IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME-
SO THAT IN ADDITION TO THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE THAT THE OPPOSITION
IT WAS STATED SO. GOING BACK TO
THE ANALYSIS WHICH I FELT
PROVIDED A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED I THINK
THAT AGAIN I AM CERTAIN THAT
THIS WOULD BE ADDRESSED- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR MESSAGE. THANK
YOU SO- I KNOW- VISITING UNITED
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE AND I.
AND TRYING TO RECONCILE WHAT YOU
WERE- EXPLAINING THE BILL WITH
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I MEAN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS WELL
REPRESENTATIVE. SEEMS TO CLEARLY
STATE LIKE I'M I'M READING FROM
THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS HERE THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW A LAWSUIT BASED
ON AN INTERIM DECISION BEFORE
THE RECORD IS COMPLETE BEFORE
ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDIES ARE
EXHAUSTED- AND BEFORE THE
PROJECT HAS BEEN APPROVED OR
DENIED I DON'T SEE HOW THAT IS
NOT. IMPACTING SEQUEL. SO WE
WANT TO GET TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE THAT. THE DEMONSTRATORS
THAT WILL NOT HAPPEN YOU WOULD
NOT HAVE LITIGATION IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS OF UP BY
THIRTY DAYS A JURISDICTION THIS
IS A FINE WHAT LEVEL OF
ENVIRONMENT REVIEW NEEDS TO BE
DONE SIXTY DAYS FOR NEGATIVE
DECLARATION AND THE YOUR FOR A
FULL BLOWN. HE I ARE WE DON'T
WANT TO TOUCH THOSE TIME LINES
AND AT THAT POINT OF THE
DILATORY TACTICS AND YOU JUST
GOT SOMEONE ON A FISHING
EXPEDITION. FROM A THEIR SAME
RELIGIOUS TO STUDY THIS FOR THAT
WITHOUT ANYTHING IN THE RECORD
TO INDICATING THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STUDY THAT'S WHEN YOU
WOULD WANT TO BRING IN THIS
PROCESS AT AFTER ALL THAT LEVELS
OF THE REMEDIES HAVE BEEN
EXHAUSTED THAT'S WHERE WE NEED
TO GET WITH THE LANGUAGE AND
GLAD TO WORK WITH WITH THIS
COMMITTEE- GOING FORWARD AND THE
TRADE TO GET TO THE LANGUAGE
THAT WORKS FOR ALL PARTIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. HI
THIS IS A WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE. AND YET AGAIN BUT REALLY
PROJECT THE DISCUSSION- YOU KNOW
I. I DO THINK IN OUR TERMS OF
OUR READING OF THAT WITHOUT THE
SERVICES WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT IT DOES BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. A
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT DATA SAID CRYSTAL CLEAR SO
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR US FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT IS A
GOOD. HELLO ALL SECOND THE BILL
. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RIVAS FLORA HI
LAURA I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH NO FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. LOADING
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MURATSUCHI
RIGHT TO CHEER I REYES. REYES I
SAY ARE TOO HIGH C. R. TO AYE
STONE. STONE NO WOULD. WOOD HI.
THE BILL SERVER TO TELL THANK
YOU RIGHT NOW IT MOVING ON THE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN YES SO
LET ME- JUST START BY SAYING
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY ACCEPT THE-
COMMITTED WOMEN'S TENNIS AND
THANK THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. THE BILL REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO REDESIGN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INCENTIVES- WE'VE MADE
GREAT PROGRESS AND-
INCENTIVIZING ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BOTH NEW VEHICLES AS
WELL AS USED VEHICLES- BUT AT A
TIME. WITH BUSH WITH THE NEWER
VEHICLES WE'VE SEEN WE NEED TO
MAKE A CHANGE TO REALLY GO AFTER
THOSE DRIVERS WHO USE THE MOST
GASOLINE AND WITH THAT- WE ARE
ASKING THEIR THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO REDESIGN THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM SO THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUPER USERS OF GASOLINE
HAVING THE LONGEST COMMUTES WE
OFTEN HAVE MANY COMMUTERS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY GOING INTO THE
BAY AREA- THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD RECEIVE THE HIGHEST
INCENTIVE BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT
TO FIND IN THE SENATE THAT WOULD
GET THEM OUT OF THEIR GASOLINE
CAR INTO A CLEAN CAR- WE THINK
THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO REALLY
LOOK AT THAT READ REDESIGNING
WE'VE MADE HUGE AMOUNT OF
SUCCESS. I GOT A LOT OF FOLKS
MOVING MOVED INTO- ELECTRIC CARS
AND CLEAN VEHICLES- AND WE THINK
THAT WITH THE PROPER INCENTIVES
WE CAN REALLY MOVE ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO USE THEIR VEHICLES A
MOUSE INTO A CLEAN VEHICLES
WITHOUT- HAVE JANELLE LONDON
HERE FROM- CULTURE. GO GIVE A
FEW REMARKS AS AS WELL AS FAR
IVANKA. RENDON ON THE PHONE.
START WITH JANELLE HEARING
COMMITTEE ROOM. YES I AM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE I'M
JANELLE LONDON WITH THE
NONPROFIT CULTURAL WORKING TO
MOVE BEYOND GASOLINE. AND
THERE'S REALLY THREE FACTORS AT
PLAY- CREATING THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL FIRST IS THE LOWEST INCOME
DRIVERS WHO ARE BURNING THE MOST
GASOLINE ARE SPENDING UPWARDS OF
25% OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON
THEIR VEHICLE FUEL- AND THEN
SECOND- WE'VE GOT A CLIMATE
CRISIS. BURNING GASOLINE AND
LIGHT DUTY CARS AND TRUCKS AS
THE SINGLE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
CARBON EMISSIONS AND CURRENT ZAB
INCENTIVES HAVE NOT BROUGHT OUR
GASOLINE CONSUMPTION DOWN WE'VE
STAYED AT FIFTEEN BILLION
GALLONS A YEAR. IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE LAST DECADE- AND THEN
FINALLY WE REACHED A POINT WHERE
OTHERS HAVE MARKET IS NO LONGER
NEW IT'S MATURE IN FACT THE
DEMAND FOR JOBS IS EXCEEDING
SUPPLY AND WE'RE ACTUALLY IN AS
THEY HAVE SHORTAGE- SO THESE
THREE FACTORS GASOLINE BURDEN
FAMILIES. THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND
THE ZIP SHORTAGE REQUIRED THAT
WE REFORM EVEY INCENTIVES- AND-
SO WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T NEED TO
KEEP INCENTIVIZING THE WEALTHIER
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T USING MUCH
GASOLINE TO SWITCH TO THE US-
BUT WE DO NEED TO MAXIMIZE
EMISSIONS CUTS BY FOCUSING ON-
FOLKS WHO ARE USING IT BUT
DRIVING THE MOST USING THE MOST
GASOLINE. AND WE DO NEED TO
MAXIMIZE EQUITY BY FOCUSING ON
THE LOW INCOME DRIVERS WHO ARE
BURNING THE MOST GASOLINE AND WE
ALSO MAKE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE SCARCE ZAB THE SCARE
SUPPLIED ZEDD'S GETS INTO THE
HANDS OF THE PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
USING IT TO DISPLACE THE MOST
GASOLINE- SO THINK ABOUT IT THIS
WAY IF WE COULD GET THE BIGGEST
GASOLINE USERS INTO STEPS. FIRST
IT WOULD TAKE NINE MILLION STEPS
ON THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA TO CUT
VEHICLE EMISSIONS IN HALF. AND
IF AS CURRENT TRENDS ARE BEARING
OUT THESE BIGGEST USERS ARE THE
LAST PEOPLE TO SWITCH DESERVES
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US TWENTY
FOUR MILLION ZAB ON THE ROAD SO
NEARLY THREE TIMES AS MANY- AND
THERE'S ANOTHER BENEFIT OUT FOR
THESE BIGGEST GASOLINE USERS. IF
THEY HAVE ENOUGH OF AN INCENTIVE
TO SWITCH TO A STEP THEY WILL BE
ADDITIONALLY SAVING A LOT OF
MONEY SO THE BIGGEST USERS ARE
SPENDING. AROUND SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR ON- ON THEIR-VEHICLE THAT FUEL SO IF THEY
SWITCHED IS ABSENT THEY COULD
SAVE. FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH AND THEY COULD USE THAT
MONEY TO MAKE THEIR MONTHLY
PAYMENTS ON THEIR EVEY- SO WE
GOT A LOT OF BENEFITS HERE THAT
ONE'S NOT COMING FROM TAXPAYER
DOLLARS- SO IN SHORT. THIS
PROGRAM MAXIMIZES EMISSIONS CUTS
AND HELPS THE DRIVERS WHO NEED
IT THE MOST SO I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY. THANK YOU. THERE'S A BOND
ON THE A PHONE LINE. YES THAT
YEAR. TAKE IT AWAY. OKAY DAISY
BARKER AT DEL AND I'D LIVE IT
WOULD KID- WHICH IS WITH RESPECT
COUNTY I LIVE WITH MY HUSBAND
AND THREE CHILDREN WE ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY DRIVING- THANK
YOU NINETY EIGHT HONDA ACCORD AT
BRADBURY RELIABLE IT REALLY
BREAKS DOWN A LOT BY. THE WAY TO
THE FINAL OF BY DOING. WHAT IT
WOULD BE THE WAY WORLD. BECAUSE
THAT BIG THAT WE'LL HAVE ONE
CAR. I DRIVE TO WORK EVERY BOARD
THE- DAYS I'D GO BACK OVER TO
WAITED TO TAKE OUR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL. LATER THAT DAY I HAVE TO
PICK UP MY KIDS FROM SCHOOL. THE
DRIVE BACK OUT TO TWO LITTLE
BOTTLES. TO PICK UP AND HAS
BEEN. BUT WORK. ALL AT ALL WE
DRY THE CAR ABOUT HOURS A DAY
COVER ABOUT HUNDRED. A HUNDRED
MILES WE ARE REALLY SUFFERING
WITH GAS PRICES GETTING THAT BUT
THAT. WOULD BE A MORE RELIABLE
CAR. WE WOULD LIKE TO GET
ELECTRIC CART BUT WE DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT GUYS RIGHT GOING
UP. AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY WILL
HELP US. MAKE THE DOWN PAYMENT
UNDER THE LEAD GUITAR. WE WOULD
USE THE SAVINGS ARE GASOLINE AND
MAKE MONTHLY PAYMENTS UNDER LET
THE CARD. WE ARE BARELY MAKING
IT RIGHT NOW WITH OUR OLD CAR
AND I GOT RIGHT. POLICE SAID AB
THIRTY SIXTIES. PROBABLY LIKE
OURS COULD NOT BE RELIED.
DEFINITELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE OF. A AB TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
SEEN NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
C. NINE ABOUT A MODERATOR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN. YOUR
ORDER OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THEIR APPEARANCE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU
HAVE A SON YOU. OKAY WITH THAT
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS WAS GARCIA.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
ORDER AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
ATTENTION ON. FOLKS WERE DRIVING
THESE LONG DISTANCES THAT HAVE
PEOPLE THAT- WORK NEAR MY
DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT AND ARE
COMMUTING TO DISTRICTS MUCH LESS
RACIST NINETY MILES AWAY- ON A
REGULAR BASIS. INCLUDING SOMEONE
ELSE OR TO FAINT OR YOU'RE A
SEPARATE BILL. OUT THERE AND SO
I DO APPRECIATE THEIR APPROACH I
JUST HAVE A QUESTION THERE'S NO
- THERE'S LANGUAGE ABOUT
PRIORITIZING- LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME INDIVIDUALS BUT THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENTS. ON ON INCOME
WITHIN IN THE PAST THAT THAT'S
BEEN A PROBLEM. CAN YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT AND ARE
YOU LOOKING TO ADDRESS THAT ARE
. HOW DO WE- YEAH. SO WHAT WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO DO IS MOVED
THE INCENTIVES TO LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES THAT'S
UP INCLUDE LANGUAGE WE DID NOT
PUT A SPECIFIC INCOME CAP I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE CONTEMPLATING AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD JUST TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLEAR BUT THE
IDEA IS DEFINITELY TO HAVE THE
INCENTIVES- BE MUCH MORE FOCUSED
FOR TO BE FOCUS PERIOD ON LOW TO
MODERATE CAN FAMILIES AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
DRIVING THE MOST. YEAH AND I'M
I'M PREPARED TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL TODAY. BUT AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. I DO THINK WE
NEED TO BE INTENTIONAL AND HAVE
CLEAR PROTECTIONS ON. ON INCOME
CAPS AREN'T SOMETHING TO
GUARANTEE. THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
TARGETING. OUR LOW LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME INDIVIDUALS OUT
WITH THIS AND THAT. THAT WE
DON'T JUST LEAVE IT UP. AND HOPE
THAT IT WORKS OUT THAT WAY YEAH
I AGREE WITH YOU AND I THINK- WE
HAVEN'T. AGREED UPON THAT
LANGUAGE UP I THINK WE'RE IT
WILL DEFINITELY BE DOING.
SOMETHING IN THE COMING WEEKS.
YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK ANY AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
ACCEPTED THE KIND OF ADDRESSES
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES YEAH WE DO.
SO- WE LIKE TO CLOSE THIS TICKET
I JUST RESPECT THEIR FIBER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BUSH'S THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED AND
SECTION THIS CALL THE ROLL.
RIVAS FLOOR- LAURA I
BOERNER HORVATH. HI FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE MATHIS NECESS IRA TO G.
RITSU CHII REYES REYES ICR TWO
SEYARTO NOW STONE. STONE I WOULD
. WHAT IF I. SACRAMENTO BILLS
DIMAS ITSELF. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
HAVE A SUMMER SUCI. THE LAST ONE
OF THE EVENING. ABOUT. SEN THANK
YOU- AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
THREE. SIX IMPROVE THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM BY REQUIRING THE A
OR B. TO CONDUCT A REGULAR
REVIEW THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S MEETING ITS OBJECTIVES
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THERE BE TO
ADOPT PUBLIC BANKING METRICS TO
TRACK THE NUMBER OF THE UNUSED
ALLOWANCES ANOTHER COMPLIANCE
INSTRUMENTS. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS CAITLYN
SUTTER BUT THEN BORROWER DEFENSE
FUND AND DAVID WEISS COP WITHIN
THAT NEXT GEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
THREE. OKAY BUT A LOT OF THIS
THE PEOPLE READ THEIR STUTTERING
THE PHONE. PERFECT GO AHEAD.
SAME HERE- AGAIN KEEP THE
MURDERS BETTER SENIOR MANAGER
FOR YOU APPOINTED AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND- AND
ALSO THE ASSEMBLY APPOINTEES THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT IS
REFERENCED IN THE BILL- THANK
YOU WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE SOLELY ON
BEHALF OF YEAH- I'M AN EASY
ACTIVITY ALONG THE BORDER OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
DIRECTION IN QUESTION. AND AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE. HOW
HAS LED THE WAY IN. CLIMATE
CHANGE. BUT IF THE CRISIS
CONTINUES TO ACCELERATE IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA KEEP
FAITH AND EXPLAINS THE THIRTIETH
MEETING AND THIS INTERACTION%
GOAL. PROVIDED BY A WELL
DESIGNED MISSION POP. APPLE
TRADE PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE SPEECH TO DEFINE A POLICY
AND A FIRM DECLINING CAPTIVATE.
ARE YOU NEEDING CLIMATE. REGULAR
EVALUATION AND STATE PROGRAMS IN
A MATTER OF GOOD PUBLIC POLICY A
PREDETERMINED SCHEDULE AND
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT PROGRAMS
ARE FOR PURPOSE AND DELIVERING
UNCLES IS IMPORTANT IN ANY. AND
AS WE SEE MORE AND MORE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE IT IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CLIMATE POLICIES OUR
AMBITIOUS ENOUGH HE PUMPED. AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE WOULD
INSTITUTE A REGULAR REVIEW WITH
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY ON THE TIMING AND SCOPE
OF POTENTIAL PROGRAM I THINK.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN
CERTAINTY OF A MISSION REDUCTION
BUT ALSO INCREASE CERTAINTY FOR
REGULATED ENTITIES. THE
INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET BY
THREE COMMITTEE AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE BOTH MADE NUMEROUS
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING ENTRY.
A REGULAR PROGRAM REVIEW WOULD
PROVIDE A PUBLIC AND DELIBERATE
PROCESS TO CONSIDER THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS INITIATIVE ON THE
EAST COAST AND THE EUROPEAN
UNION EMISSIONS TRADING SYSTEM-
UNDERGO REGULAR PROGRAM. AND
WASHINGTON STATE WILL INCLUDE
ONE AND IT'S HAPPENING THAT'S
PROGRAM LAUNCHING NEXT YEAR. YEP
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARIE
FIFTEENTH NEAR STEP ON THIS
ISSUE- AND WE HAD VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION CAN IT
STAFF TO REFINE THE FINDING. OF
THIS REVIEW AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK WE HAVE DAVID ON THE PHONE
AS WELL.
BUT A MODERATE WE HAVE A DAVID.
ON THE PHONE. ARE YOU ONLINE
HERE LATELY YEAH HERE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
JERRY THIS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE. MY
NAME IS GETTING. DAVID WEISS CUP
A MISSING YOUR POLICY ADVISOR
FROM NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA. ACTION
SPORTS POLICIES AND PROGRAMS
THAT FOSTER AFFECTED INEQUITABLE
. GIVE ME CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTIONS. WE'VE BEEN CLOSELY
INVOLVED WITH DEPENDING AND
WORKING TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE WE SUPPORT IN THE
BALLPARK START WORK ON CAP AND
TRADE AND RECOGNIZED THE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS THAT IT
DELIVERS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT HAS BECOME
MORE CLEAR EVERY DAY TO THE
STATE IS NOT ON TRACK TO ACHIEVE
ITS TWENTY THIRTY EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TARGET WE THINK IT
MAKES SENSE TO ENSURE THE CAP
AND TRADE IN ALL OF OUR CLIENTS
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AS WELL AS
POSSIBLE. NUMBERS INDEPENDENT
ANALYSES FROM ACADEMICS
INVESTORS AND OTHERS HAVE RAISED
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE PROGRAM'S
ABILITY TO DELIVER ITS
FORECASTED GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. AND IN A
NUTSHELL THIS IS BECAUSE TOO
MANY ALLOWANCES ARE BEING MADE
AVAILABLE AND BANKED IN PRIVATE
HANDS. DECEMBER'S THE PROGRAM'S
ABILITY TO SPUR INVESTMENT AND
BEHAVIOR CHANGES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST INDUSTRIAL
POLLUTERS. THAT WE WILL NEED TO
SEE IF WE ARE HIT OR TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. LET'S GO ASK THE
AGENCY TO FIRST CONDUCT A
REGULAR ISSUE OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AND SHARE MORE
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND DYNAMICS OF THE
MARKET WITH LEGISLATORS AND THE
PUBLIC AND TO AUTHORIZES CARB TO
IT'S DESIGNED TO MEET ITS POLICY
OBJECTIVES. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
STRIKES THE NEED TO BALANCE
BETWEEN ALLOWING THE AGENCY
FLEXIBILITY TO DO ITS JOB. WHILE
ALSO GIVING LAWMAKERS AND THE
PUBLIC INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE FUTURE OF
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM. THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT. TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. CNN ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE. C. NINE MADAM
MODERATOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE OF THE PHONES.
CURRENT THE PARTNER OPPOSITION
IS ONE ONE ZERO. WHAT BEGAN IS
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT DEPARTMENT
ZERO. EDIBLE WATCH ONLINE NUMBER. ONE TWENTY FOUR. WELL ABIGAIL
MILE ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WALKED THANKS WE WILL
VOTES OF ONE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THE THOUGHT HAD. AMATEUR
NUMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
BE. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MARIN CUBANS CHAIR
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE- BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CENOVUS RESEARCH WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK PANDA THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
SAID TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
MEXICAN POLITICAL. RIVAS FLORA.
FLORA NO BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN
RIGHT FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NUMBER
TWO G. HI RESEARCH THE AYE REYES
REYES I SAY ARE SO. SEYARTO NO
STONE. STONE I WOULD. WOOD HI.
THE BILL SERVICES OUT. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE GONNA START FROM
THE TOP START WITH CONSENT
CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH WITH IT WE GET READY
HERE SO WE'LL DO IT ONCE. AND A
- AREA START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SET CALENDARS AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE GRAYSON. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY EIGHT KALRA.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SEVEN STONE
. ABSENT MEMBER FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE STONE. STONE HI.
CONSENT IS OUT WITH A VOTE. YOU
DID EARLIER. VICARIOUSLY YOU
VOTED. BUT THE. FILE ITEM ONE AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ARAMBULA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I MARTUCCI
FIVE MURATSUCHI I. REYES. REYES
I STONE STONE I. SEVEN BILL THE
SEVEN THE VOTE ITSELF ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT CUNNINGHAM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING NOT VOTING
RIGHTS TO CHECK UP ON.
MURATSUCHI NOT VOTING. AND REYES
. REYES NOT PROTEIN THAT MEASURE
FAILS. I. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE THAT MEASURE FAILS HAS FIVE
VOTES. OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE AB. TWENTY ONE FORTY
ONE. AB I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
CUNNINGHAM'S BILL OKAY. R. O.
THANK YOU AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
EIGHT REYES FROM NOT VOTING TO I
. THAT HAS EXPERTS. WILL SIX
PERSONALITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ABSENT MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I SEVEN OF
THE LAST SEVEN VOTES IT'S
OUTLIVING AVAILABLE FOR AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN GARCIA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN I SEVEN
BUCKS PHYLLIS SEVEN VOTED OUT
MOVING THE BALLOT NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE GARCIA
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ABSENT MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I THAT HAS
NINE STILL HAS NINE VOTES ITSELF
FILE ITEM SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX GARCIA MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT
MEMBER. FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN HI.
IT HAS NINE OF THOSE NINE VOTES
IN ITS ABOUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE- WITH OF AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY IRWIN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBER
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I THAT HAS
NINE BILLS BILLS NINE VOTED OUT.
BY LEVEL LEVEL AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MURATSUCHI. I ITEM ELEVEN AB.
TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR. NOT
VOTING REYES OUR REYES I STILL
STONE HI. HAS NINE THE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES OUT ON THE BALLOT IN
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE CORK THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ABSENT MEMBER WOULD. WOOD I. THE
BOSTON MOTEL MOVING THE FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN- AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY TWO RIVAS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE MOTION ABSENT
MEMBER FRIEDMAN RIGHT FRIEDMAN I
MATHIS. NO MATHIS NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE RIGHT TO G. I. REYES. REYES
I STONE STONE HI. SENATE BILL
SEVEN VOTES WITHOUT MOVING THE
FILE ITEM NINETEEN PHYLUM
NINETEEN AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
SEVEN FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SEVEN SEVEN VOTE
TO TELL WHO IN ABOUT ELEVEN
TWENTY AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I MATHIS NO MATHIS
NUMBER TEACHING. RESEARCH SHE
AYE REYES. REYES AYE STONE STONE
AYE. THE DALLAS SEVEN VOTERS
MOVING THE FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
IN OUR FINAL BILL AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY MURATSUCHI. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE ABSENT MEMBER FRIEDMAN
HI. FRIEDMAN I REYES. REYES AYE
STONE STONE I. THAT HAS SEVEN
LETTERS YEP THANK YOU. HAVE A
LEVEL OF SEVEN VOTERS OUT AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS MEETING
WILL BE ADJOURNED. WELL THE
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR AVAILABLE.